Ich glaube, das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Das war's für heute.
Okay, exzellent.
Was?
Wir müssen gucken, ob Bilder funktionieren, ich vergesse immer welches das ist.
Ähm, die, die hatten mal ein Bug, dass die glaub ich keine JPG supportet haben.
Irgendwas war da ganz, ganz merkwürdig, ich glaub das geht mittlerweile.
Aber gibt's gehen wahrscheinlich, immer noch nicht.
Aber gut, das ist auch eine Foto-App meinetwegen, aber ich bin mal gespannt, ob die mittlerweile
Fotoalbums unterstützen oder ob man ordentlich die Informationen aus Bildern auslesen kann
und so.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Lyonabomber97, Dankeschön für 23 Monate Hyper-Subscription hier.
Dazu ist ja eigentlich nur zu sagen, dass war eigentlich der falsche Knopf, eigentlich
wollte ich das hier sagen oder sagen lassen.
Nextloud war schon immer nice, da, siehst du mal, so gehen die Ansichten da drüber
auseinander.
Also ich hab bisher fast nur negative Erfahrungen mit Nextloud gemacht, obwohl ich den Kram
laufen habe seit paar Jahren.
Ich kann auch gleich ein bisschen erzählen, warum es mir nicht gefällt.
Genauso wie immer, nice.
Also die Suche geht immer noch nicht out of the box.
Gibt es brauchbare Alternativen, ja die gibt es tatsächlich, wenn man nicht das Gesamtpaket
braucht.
Also wenn man das Gesamtpaket haben will, also den ganzen Apps, Kaldorf, Katdorf und
sonst was, diese Talk-Geschichten und Collaboration-Geschichten, im Gesamtpaket gibt es eigentlich zumindest
zum Selbsttausen nichts wirklich als Alternative zu Nextcloud.
Jetzt wollen wir OneCloud außen vor lassen, aber für Einzelteile gibt es bessere Alternative
und wenn es dir wirklich nur um das File-Synch geht, nimm keine Ahnung Syncthing oder C-File
oder sowas, das funktioniert meiner Ansicht nach besser.
Leute ich hab immer noch ein bisschen Kopfweh, seit ich den 5G-Chip von Bill Gates drinne
hab, hab ich Kopfweh.
Vielleicht strahlt es, es ist einfach die 5G-Strahlung.
Kacke FPS ist back, naja gut bei mir ist es schon 8 Jahre back.
Tobi, danke für den Zapp, 5 Monate, huge, ich hoffe ich hab nix übersehen.
Ja schön, dass ihr alle am Start seid, ja ich bin die ganze Zeit schon immer wieder
hin und her am überlegen, ob ich mich endlich in Nextcloud bei mir wegschmeiße, aber mal
gucken, mal gucken, mal gucken erstmal, erstmal die VM starten, ich glaube ich machs nicht
auf dem Raspberry Pi, kannste einfach Docker-Container starten, gut ist.
Könnten sie in der Qt-VM machen Leute, sollen wir sie in der Qt-VM machen, ne wir machen
uns nicht in der Qt-VM, die Qt-VM ist ein Urhalt Ubuntu, da läuft das nicht richtig
drauf.
Aber ich starte mal eine Runde für euch, die Qt-VM, me weep me spam modbucker if ban,
es gibt so viele sinnlose Copypastas, so jetzt einmal Qt-Ladung für heute und dann mach
ich wieder aus.
Ok genug, genug Qt für heute, ich steh vor M starten, hat eigentlich jemand den Sebaro
mal in letzter Zeit gesehen?
Schon eine Weile nicht mehr da gewesen, der Excel Sebaro, gut das kann er ja sein, das
überlasse ich jedem selbst, ok was ist das, ach das ist eine komische dumme Windows Funktion
da.
So warum hab ich nur 15G Festplatten Platz frei hier in meiner VM, das muss erstmal gefixt
werden, das muss erstmal gefixt werden, Moment, erstmal Firefox, ups falscher, erstmal gucken,
Hallo, erstmal ein bisschen Platz machen, erstmal ein bisschen Platz machen, DNS-Stells
konnte nicht gelöscht werden, ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Das ist deine Qt-VM, oh ja die sieht äußerst cute aus, Trashsteen, ach guck mal, guck mal
ich hab wieder 10G frei easy, Dogger Kram läuft auch, ich guck mal kurz ganz schnell,
was hier so viel Platz belegt, noch ein bisschen was frei geben kann, ok NPM, was sonst, klar,
platformer, oh ok, aber Javascript ist klar, also what the fuck, eine, das hat doch gar
nicht mehr auf, ok Cache, ja meinetwegen, Downloads, ach die ganzen Window-Eso-Gedöns,
weg, Windows XP, weg, Ordner Dance Game, weiß nicht ob wir das fahren, aber wahrscheinlich
brauchen wir das nicht mehr, weg, Windows XP, das lass ich mal da, das brauch ich schon
für ein Video, Windows weg, Local, Share, ah das Jet Brand, ok, jetzt haben wir ein
bisschen Platz, das reicht, so, die ganzen Windows Isos ja, Windows Isos und Raspberry
Pi Isos hat sich halt mit der Zeit so angesammelt, was im Default, keine Ahnung, in dem Chrome,
ah da haben wir mal versucht ein Chrome zu kompilieren, kann das sein, aber da haben wir
versucht ein Chrome zu kompilieren, was ich richtig funktionierte, ich glaub schon, ok,
das lösche ich auch mal, ja ich glaube ich hab versucht ein Chrome zu kompilieren, das
hat nicht funktioniert, DNS-Stell ist ok, ich hab keine Ahnung was DNS-Stell ist, aber
jetzt haben wir wieder ordentlich Platz, Chrome braucht ja auch irgendwie gefühlt 3TB RAM
zum kompilieren, ist doch scheiße egal, macht es irgendeinen Unterschied, ich weiß in zwei
Buchstaben, Chrome auf dem Hetzner Server, das können wir machen, übrigens die Hetzner
Geschichte, wir haben uns geeinigt, demnächst gibt es Sellout Streams, 2 Sellout Streams
im Monat, ein Sellout Video im Monat, Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat, wer noch sein 20 Euro VM
Hetzner Cloud Gutschein einlösen will, der feste Anzahl mit 2 Streams im Monat ist ja
nicht das Problem, ne ich mach doch viel mehr als 2 Streams, ich mach ja schon fast 2 Streams
in der Woche, ich mach mindestens 2 Streams in der Woche, so dann schauen wir uns jetzt
erstmal an was Neues gibt, doch wir hatten ein Stream für 21 als es rausgekommen ist
und da fand ich immer noch nicht gut und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich jetzt 22 auch
nicht gut finde aber man weiß ja nie und außerdem ist das ganze dann auch Easy Content, wenn
ich eh schon weiß, dass ich es mir nicht gefällt, so also guck mal Next Cloud 22, also ich hab
schon ein bisschen gelesen, es gibt tatsächlich diesmal eine Funktion wo ich wirklich, kurz
bisschen kühler machen hier, eine Funktion wo ich wirklich gespannt drauf bin, ist das
der News Post, nämlich die haben angeblich jetzt den Wiki eingebaut, ah guck mal die
haben sogar, Moment Announcement 47 Minuten da, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, gar
kein Peps mehr, Dankeschön für einen Sub, der Stufe, ich wollte jetzt sagen für einen
Monat aber das ergibt da eigentlich keinen Sinn, Stufe 1 Sub, ein richtig echter Stufe
1 Sub, kein Prime Sub, sondern ein richtiger 5 Head Move, ja also für, ne ohne Mist also
für Hetzner Videos und Streams und so hab ich echt keine Content Probleme, Videotechnisch
ist ganz einfach, ich hab so viele Storys die ich erzählen kann und die sich eher oftmals
halt um Technik Kram drehen, da kann ich erzählen und Streams machen wir halt irgendwas was
sich anbietet, Cloud mäßig, Server mäßig, machen wir keine Ahnung von Linux Server einrichten
bis irgendwelche Firewall Geschichten oder Sachen, House, keine Ahnung gibt's ja tausend
Varianten, nein AD werde ich nie machen, also was ihr nie bei mir im Stream sehen werdet,
aber das habt ihr euch wahrscheinlich auch schon gedacht, was ihr nie bei mir im Stream
sehen werdet ist Windows Administration, wobei haben wir nicht mal einen Windows 2000 Server,
äh 2020, 2018 Server oder was ist denn das letzte überhaupt Windows, was ist denn die
aktuelle Windows Server Version, 2019, haben wir nicht einen Windows 2019 Server Stream
mal gemacht und ich hab mich permanent weggekackt, wie bescheuert die Sachen unter Windows gemacht
sind, ich erinnere mich noch dunkel, da haben wir ganz grausame Dinger gemacht, irgendwie
den DNS in diesem komischen Assistent eingerichtet und festgestellt, dass das wirklich haarsträumendes
Weird Champing ist bei Microsoft und ich nicht verstehen kann wie irgendjemand auf dieser
Welt freiwillig Windows administriert, haben wir Windows Admins bei uns im Chat, nicht
freiwillig, ja gut das ist okay, das ist okay, das ist okay, wenn man dazu gezwungen wird
dann lass ich das gelten, ja Leute ich mach mal, ich mach mal, dass ihr weniger Sonnenbrille
anzieht, ich mach mal Dark Mode an, ja, so mal gucken ob ich die Musik Cloud Stelle richtig
getroffen hab, passt, also schauen wir mal, Next Cloud, also das Ding heißt ja seit ein
paar Versionen Next Cloud Hub, weil das dann viel socialiger ist, warum weiß ich nicht,
warum das Hub heißt, aber das ist jetzt viel, viel agiler.
Du machst auf der Arbeit einen Mix aus Windows und Linux, lass mich raten, ein Mix aus Windows
und Linux heißt, ihr habt jede Menge Windows Clients und ein paar Linux Server und vielleicht
irgendwie ein Windows AD oder so, übrigens, der hat das, wollte ich grad sagen, der hat
direkt geplockt, weil der Twitch Filter gleich wieder Racism vermutet hat, weil du geschrieben
hast Yep und die haben vermutet, das muss eine rassistische Message über Japaner sein,
das kann nicht Zustimmung sein, deswegen wurde das gerade geplockt, Yep ist ok, aber Jap
ist nicht ok, die sind halt mittlerweile echt über vorsichtig was das angeht, ich hab letztens
in einem Twitch Chat geschrieben, irgendwas, ich weiß gar nicht mehr den Satz, aber ich
weiß das Wort noch, was ich drinne, also ich hab nen Satz im Twitch Chat, das ist weniger
als und das deutsche Wort weniger hat er geplockt, weil weniger, das geht überhaupt nicht, das
muss man plocken, das ist nicht möglich, also zeig mal her, was gibts denn neues, ich
mein ich verstehs, dass man so Filter einbaut, da hab ich ja keine Schmerzen, das wär vielleicht
cool wenn man nicht defaultmäßig in deutschsprachigen Streams die Filter für internationale Streams
macht, naja, wenn ich Z-File auf Raspberry Pi installier kann ich zwei Festplatten spiegeln,
das kannst du sicherlich machen, aber dafür gibts deutlich bessere Varianten als, also
wenn du zwei Festplatten spiegeln willst würde ich das nicht unbedingt mit Z-File machen,
also da hast du, es gibt die online Variante, nee, jetzt muss ich anders sagen, es gibt
die ausfallfreie Variante und die etwas stromsparendere und lebensdauersparendere Variante für
die festplatten, wo das aber dann die festplatte von hand umschalten muss, also zum beispiel,
was du machen kannst, also erstens muss ich sagen, der Raspberry Pi ist generell kein
gutes nass, aber sag mal dahingestellt, geh mal von außen, machst das damit, wenn du
zwei festplatten spiegeln sollst, das einfachste was du machen kannst ist, es ist Linux, gibt
es wieder zigtausend Varianten, wir fangen jetzt mal nicht mit ZFS an, aber du kannst,
also die einfachste Variante ist, du machst MD-Rate, MD-Rate 1, das ist quasi das gleiche,
was du sonst mit so einer hardware-rate-karte machst, nur das Linux das in software für
dich macht, ist super, ist besser meiner Meinung nach, wie eine rate-karte, weil du kannst die
festplatten einfach an jedes x-beliebige andere linux stecken und einlesen, machst ein MD-Rate
1, MD-Rate 1, dann sind die zwei festplatten immer gespiegelt, aber beide festplatten
müssen an sein.
So, die nächste Variante ist das, was der Sirius Max schon geschrieben hat, ach quatsch,
das bissel, also wenn du damit ok bist, einen Raspberry Pi als nass zu verwenden, ja dann
geht, das ist natürlich noch auf die CPU, aber das macht es dann auch noch mehr fett,
bei einem normalen Rechner ist das nicht so wild, es sei denn du bewegst dich in 10G-Kreisen,
aber das ist mit Magnet-Festplatten eh schwierig, MD-Rate ist eine super Geschichte, so was
aber einfacher ist, wenn du einfach nur willst, dass das ganze ausfallen sicher ist, dann
macht es mit R-Sync, dann hängen die zweite festplatte dran und lass einmal nachts die
festplatten sünden über R-Sync zum Beispiel, das hat nen Vorteil gegenüber Raid, 1, wenn
du deine Daten ausversehen löscht oder ausversehen bewusst, oder was hat, nee bewusst, wenn du
deine Daten ausversehen schrottest auf der einen festplatte, dann sind sie auf der Backup-Festplatte
noch da, deswegen ist, das ist ja das Problem an Raid, wenn man Raid quasi als Backup verwendet,
ist das dumme, wenn du absichtlich oder, nee ich putze das anders aus, wenn du unabsichtlich
was löscht, was aber ne normale lösch-Operation ist, also du drückst ausversehen entfernen
Enter oder sowas, dann löscht er das, dann ist es auf beiden festplatten weg, weil das
Raid dafür da ist das zu spiegeln, machst du quasi so nen verzögerten Sync mit R-Sync,
dann hast du das Problem nicht, dann hast du ja nämlich einmal nachts den Sync und wenn
du dann ausversehen was löscht, kannst du sagen aha, gestern auf meiner externen Festplatte
ist es noch drauf, also wenn du das einfach nur als Foto-Backup brauchst, dann würd ich
es mir tatsächlich einfach machen und irgendeine fertige, also entweder machst n R-Sync einmal
in der Nacht rüber oder ich würd irgendeine fertige Backup-Software nehmen, die kann das
dann auch schön rotierend machen, dass du dann sagen kannst, ok sieben Tage lang incrementales
Backup, einmal in der Woche nen neues oder aufheben, nen Tag, ne Woche, nen Monat, nen
Jahr, immer mit Abstand, dass du jetzt nicht irgendwie 365 Backups hast oder so, muss man
sich ein bisschen was überlegen, aber die richtige Raid-Variante würd ich nicht unbedingt
machen wenn du nen Foto-Backup brauchst.
Ich mein klar, du kannst auch C-File verwenden und dein Foto-Ordner einfach auf drei verschiedene
Rechner-Synken, das funktioniert auch, aber bei Sync hast du ein ähnliches Problem wie
bei Raid 1, wenn du das irgendwo löscht aus Versehen auf einem der Rechner, dann synkt
es sich überall anders hin und ist da auch weg, das heißt es ist halt, das ist eben sonst
Sync.
Na gut, so, schauen wir uns mal an, was gibt's denn neues bei Nextcloud, Hab 22, Yep Hab,
ja, was denn das, Meta-Most oder sowas, ne, Mastodon, Mastodon, ist das nicht so ein Mammut,
Hab OMV mit Hardware-Raid 5 und dazu noch extra Raid 1 für Backup von Raid 5, das ist jetzt
aber schon ein bisschen übertrieben, oder, da brauchst du ja, also es ist dann eine Art
Raid 51 oder so, das ist ein bisschen übertrieben, dann würd ich lieber gleich ein Raid 6 machen.
Ja gut, wenn ich mein, du musst es im Endeffekt wissen, ne, aber das heißt ja, du brauchst
da mal, sag mal, du hast hier 3 Festplatten und dann brauchst du nochmal 3 Festplatten
um die zu Miron, das ist dann quasi wirklich so eine Art Raid 51, kann man machen, wobei
man sagen muss, ja, ne, kann man machen, ja klar, ne, hab ich schon nicht ausprobiert,
hab ich jetzt aber auch letztens auf Hacker-News gelesen, dass das ganz gut sein soll, weil
sicherlich nicht jeder Bock hat, sich mit ZFS zu beschäftigen, wobei ich persönlich
ZFS auch gut finde, man muss aber ZFS, also ZFS hat auch seine Fallstriche, ja, zum Beispiel,
dass du aufpassen musst, dass du deine Festplatte komplett voll machst und sowas, du musst auf
jeden Fall dran denken, dass du einen Quota setzt, so bei 95% und sowas, ich weiß offiziell
wird 70% empfohlen, aber das ist Schwachsinn für den Heimgebrauch, ja, also bei ZFS muss
man schon ein bisschen aufpassen.
Du brauchst einen Quota, dass du es nicht komplett voll machst, weil ZFS ist RIP, wenn
du die Festplatte komplett voll machst und du hast auch ein paar andere Handling-Probleme,
die du halt lernen musst, ja, Hacker-News, also das hier meine ich, das heißt ja gar
nicht Hacker-News, das heißt jetzt eigentlich der Y-Combinator, warum auch immer die so
heißt, keine Ahnung, aber das ist eigentlich so die News-Seite, die alle Hacker-Mans lesen,
also ich weiß, die Seite sieht ultra beschissen aus, aber das mögen Hacker-Mans, also wenn
ihr eine News-Seite seht, wo ihr auch in Google und Microsoft und Apple bezogenen Themen in
den Kommentaren die einen oder anderen Google-Mitarbeiter, Apple oder Microsoft-Mitarbeiter finden
wollt, dann ist das die News-Seite der Wahl, wobei die sieht halt wirklich kacke aus, aber
das ist eigentlich so intimmäßig somit die beste News-Seite, sieht auch so wie Reddit
für Arme, ja, ja schon ein bisschen, aber man kann, wollt grad sagen, die haben doch
bestimmt auch noch ein Feed, ne, oh ich hab Kopfweh wegen der scheiß Impfung, wobei
ich weiß nicht, ob es an der Impfung liegt, keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist es auch einfach
so Kopfweh, aber es ist zeitlich, kommt schon gut zusammen, also jetzt schauen wir uns endlich
mal an, was geht denn hier los, was haben sie denn hier gemacht, also wir gucken uns
nicht das Ankündigungsvideo an, vielleicht haben wir ja Glück und es gibt auf YouTube
eine kleinere Nextcloud 22 Zusammenfassung, die wir uns angucken können, der guckt aber
nicht so freundlich, ok, 1 Stunde 18, nein, nein, das gucken wir uns nicht, also, gucken
wir mal hier, das hat richtig viele News da, ne, hat's nicht, cool, das sieht kein, also
schauen wir uns mal an, was gibt's denn neues, also hier, Nextcloudhub 22, weite, breitbandige
Impro...
Weitrange, was ist denn das, große Bandbreite, große Bandbreite an Verbesserungen für das
moderne digitale Büro, aha, neue Workflows, Import New Collaboration Features in Talk Groupware
and Files, das ist ja was, muss ich sagen, das ist für mich als Privatbenutzer vollkommen
uninteressant und das ist auch so ein Punkt, wo ich ein bisschen Bedenken habe bei Nextcloud,
die Features, die die einbauen, sind zu 90% Features, die mich persönlich nicht jucken
und die Apps, die dabei sind und die seit 3 Jahren Fehler haben, werden nicht besser,
ich kann's verstehen, dass die Geld verdienen müssen, ne, das ist klar, also du kannst
jetzt als Firma, also als, ich weiß nicht, welches Unternehmen dahinter steckt, nicht
einfach sagen, ok, ich mach das alles, dass es super geil für die Heimanwender ist, aber
ich verdiene an den Heimanwender nichts, das ergibt schon irgendwie Sinn, aber ich glaube,
man muss da so ein gutes, glaube, man muss da so ein gutes Mittelfeld finden und ob
man Talk, also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, wenn ich, also sollte ich mal wirklich in
die Lage kommen, dass ich keine Ahnung, sagen wir mal, dort wo ich jetzt arbeite, die Firma
geht pleite oder so, ja, dass ich müsste mir, ich müsste mir irgendwas anderes suchen und
ich hätte das irgendwie eilig und ich würde irgendwo landen, wo ich mich keine Ahnung
um Collaboration Tools oder sonst was kümmern müsste, irgend so eine kleine Klitsche, ich
würde im Leben kein Nextcloud installieren, ich sage euch wie es ist, ich bin zwar kein
großer Microsoft Fan, aber ich würde den Dingrahmen installieren, der funktioniert,
ich würde den entweder Teams installieren, also irgendeine Teams Setup Geschichte machen
und einen Wiki hinstellen und gut ist, ich würde da gar nicht erst mit Nextcloud rum
hantieren oder wir machen gleich einen Discord Server, wenn das die Datenschutzbeauftragten
zulassen, dann machen wir einen Discord Server, Teams buckt ständig rum, ja aber Teams wird
auch ständig weiterentwickelt und verbessert, also bei Teams kannst du eigentlich davon
ausgehen, wenn Teams jetzt einen etwas größeren Buck hat, dann ist der innerhalb von ein paar
Tagen weg und bei Nextcloud, tja, guck dir die Foto App an, gut also gucken wir mal weiter,
biggest improvements Nextcloud 22 sind User Defined Groups, Circles, okay das ist für
mich als Privatanwender vollkommen irrelevant, aber okay, ja wenn man das in der Business
Umgebung einsetzt, verstehe ich das, also ich kann, ich muss ja sagen, ich bin der Meinung,
Teams ist das beste der schlechten Collaboration Systeme, das hat Probleme, aber ich verwende
das jetzt selbst seit eineinhalb Jahren und ich muss sagen, es geht mir auch an vielen
Stellen auf den Sack, aber es wurde mit der Zeit immer besser und aktuell ist das echt
okay, das einzige Problem was ich noch mit Teams bei uns habe ist, dass die Anrufe von
meinem normalen Telefon nicht an Teams kommen und ich nicht mit Teams bei normalen Telefon
anrufen kann, gut das verwende ich in Teams gar nicht, das verwende ich in Teams gar nicht,
ich downloade das und mache es auf, ich glaube, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe noch nicht
einmal versucht im PDF in Teams anzugucken, Teams wird auch nie hundertprozentig fertig
sein, die sind ja permanent am rumbasteln, ich finde Teams mittlerweile wirklich okay,
wie würdest du eine Windows XP VM absichern, ganz einfach, kein Internetzugang, fertig,
da musst du nichts großartig absichern, einfach kein Internetzugang und gut ist, ich meine,
was hast du da mit vor, also, also ins Internet gehen, na gut, wenn du ins Internet gehen
willst, dann, also wenn du damit unbedingt ins Internet musst, ja, dann würde ich mir
das in etwas anderes überlegen.
Es gibt gar keinen aktuellen Chrome und Firefox mehr für XP, du fängst dir auf jeden Fall
was ein, auf jeden Fall, früher oder später, ich meine, nicht zwangsläufig, wenn du nur
auf hundertprozentig vertrauenswürdige Webseiten gehst, dann nicht, aber so normale Surfen
fängst du dir garantiert früher oder später was ein, so, also was haben wir noch, Groups
ist für mich irrelevant, Integrated Chat Task Management, okay, da bin ich mal gespannt,
weil die aktuelle To Do App ist ziemlicher Müll, Easy Approval Workflow, okay, irgendwelche
ITIL Geschichten brauche ich auch nicht, Documents, Signatures, okay, Integrated Knowledge Management,
da bin ich gespannt, ob die das Wiki ordentlich integriert haben, da bin ich wirklich mal
gespannt, das könnte tatsächlich eine Funktion sein, die ich verwende, die Software für
die Heizung läuft nur auf Windows XP, ja gut, dann ist ja einfach, dann mach das Ding einfach
nicht ins Internet, dann lass das Ding einfach nicht ins Internet, wenn du das nur für die
Steuerung von deiner Heizung brauchst, dann muss die Windows XP VM ja nicht ins Internet,
das ist aber nur, wenn sie von außen erreichbar ist, alles andere kann ich, also vermute ich
mal, alles andere kann ich mir nicht, alles andere wäre nicht realistisch, ne, ne, ne
Windows XP Installation, die nicht von außen erreichbar ist und einfach nur an ist, der
passiert auch nix, genau, okay, also das ist das einzige was mich jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen
interessiert an der neuen Version, ich hab nicht die Zertifizierung gemacht, die hab
ich nicht gemacht, ich hab mittlerweile schon drei Azure-Schulungen über mich ergehen lassen
und zwei davon waren ne Woche, Wochen, jeweils ne Woche lang oder 4 Tage lang und ich muss
dir ehrlich sagen, die Azure-Schulungen sind, ich bin Arsch, ich sag jetzt einfach mal wie
es ist, die Azure-Schulungen sind nur gut, wenn du irgendjemand hast, der auf diese Zettel
steht, weil zumindest waren die Azure-Schulungen bei mir so, allerdings ich vermute mal, dass
die überall anders auch so sind, weil wir haben den Trainer gefragt und er hat gemeint,
er darf diese Schulung gar nicht anders machen, diese Schulungen müssen einheitlich, egal
wer diese Schulung macht, immer ähnlich ablaufen, also wenn ihr ne Azure-Schulung macht, sie
ist folgend, gehen wir mal von aus ihr macht diesen, was ist das, 901, diesen Basic-Admin,
4 Tage, war das 901, Azure, war das 901, Azure Fundamentals, genau, das ist 4 Tage glaub
ich lang, ihr macht diese AZ-901, 4 Tage und im Prinzip läuft das so ab, der Trainer macht
ne offizielle Microsoft-Powerpoint-Präsentation an, klickt die mit euch durch und liest die
vor, das ist kein Witz, so laufen diese Schulungen und danach gibt es ab und zu mal immer nen
Test Lab, das sind so vorgefertigte Umgebungen, die man auf Knopfdruck starten kann und da
sollst du dann solche Sachen machen wie leg mal ne VM an, leg mal ne externe IP an der
VM und sonst wie, aber und das ist das große Problem an Microsoft, an diesen ganzen Microsoft-Schulungen,
die sagen mich mach das und du hast ne halbe Stunde Zeit, nein, die sagen klicke jetzt
auf Einstellungen, klicke jetzt auf IP hinzufügen, klicke jetzt auf IP auswählen, klicke jetzt
auf diese Domain, also ich mein diese Übungen für diese Azure-Geschichten ist nicht was
wo du wirklich lernst, sondern das sind 5 Seiten mit Anleitungen die du nacheinander
durchklicken musst, das heißt du lernst nichts, man lernt ja nur wenn man selbst denken muss
und selbst sich das angucken muss, also man lernt nicht wie man den Kram benutzt dadurch
dass man jetzt irgendwie 20 mal den gleichen Scheiß durchgeklickt hat, ist aber in vielen
Fundamental Searchs, ich weiß aber das ist kacke, das ist Müll, deswegen finde ich sind
die Azure-Schulungen auch für n Arsch, ja gut, manche Leute sind halt unbelehrbar.
Ne, das ist Microsoft Schulungslogik, das bei anderen Sachen auch so, deswegen sind die
Dinger meistens kacke.
Ok, was haben wir denn sonst noch, Group for Improvements, das ist mir auch, bring a Trash
Feature in Kalender, das heißt ich kann Kalenderevent traschen, aha, Next Cloud Mail Features Improved,
das wäre tatsächlich mal gut, weil Next Cloud Mail war bis zur letzten Version kompletter
Trash und ich meine damit nicht den Kalendertrash, sondern Next Cloud Mail war unbenutzbar, da
haben wir die Basic Funktionen gefehlt, du konntest glaube ich bis zur letzten Version
oder vorletzten Version, ich will mir gar nicht mehr verstehen, konntest du keine Mail
in einem Ordner verschieben?
Was ist das für ne Mail App, Alter, so, also gucken wir mal weiter, Integrated Compression
Info, ok, Universal Search, ok Leute, da bin ich mal gespannt, ob die Suche jetzt richtig
funktioniert, die Suche war immer mal, also mega Paint Champ in Next Cloud und hat nie
richtig funktioniert.
Ok, Next Cloud Hub ist optimalist und bla bla bla, ok, das wars, ach ne, jetzt kommen
die Features im Detail, Knowledge Management hier, ok, das ist ein Wiki im Endeffekt, das
schauen wir uns gleich mal an, ok, dieser Editor sieht Paint Champ aus, ich glaube nicht,
dass ich das verwenden will, das ist so ein Visivic Editor, das ist das Schlimmste was
es gibt, kein Wim, Grinch, es muss ja nicht mal ein Wim sein, aber irgendwas mit Markthorn
Support oder meinetwegen, meinetwegen, die Option zumindest umzuschalten, ja, Visivic,
Alter, Chet, wer weiß nicht was Visivic ist, Visivic man, Chet, schon etwas cringe, Chet,
siehst du das ist was du bekommst, das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich beschissenen Abkürzung,
Visivic, schon etwas cringe, Chet, minimal cringe, ja, das sind halt diese, diese, diese
Minimal Cringe
Ja, das sind halt diese
Was ich damit meine ist das ist so ein Textfeld Editor
Wo du Buttons hast für
Dick, also für
Bold Text und für
Kursiv und Überschrift
Gucken wir uns gleich mal an
Da spricht doch kein Mensch so aus
Wie willst du es denn sonst
Aussprechen
WZW
Nein das spricht so aus
So ähnlich zumindest
Wir gucken jetzt mal
Ok was war bei mir jetzt
Falsch
WZW
Hab Recht
Chat
Das war jetzt das eine Thema
Wo der Chat mal nicht recht hatte
Ich hab gesagt WZW
Man versteht doch was
Gemeint ist
Nicht 1 zu 0 Chat
01 Chat
Das ist 0 Max
Je nachdem wie man das sieht
User Define Groups
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht
New Workflows juckt mich auch nicht
Integrated Chat und Task Management
Könnte mich interessieren falls die To Do App jetzt halbwegs was taucht
Document Signing ist mir egal
Approval Workflow ist mir auch egal
Ich überleg gerade ob ich das erzählen darf
Ja doch da hab ich wahrscheinlich erzählt
Ich hab auf der Arbeit
ein Ticket aufgemacht
Und
Sie haben sich jetzt bei uns
Überlegt
Dass wir Zeit
Erfassung
Über so ein komisches Confluence Plugin
Machen wir hatten früher eine extra
Zeit Erfassungs Software
Die gekoppelt ist auch mit dem
Mit der Karte
Wenn man unten am Eingang reingeht
Und sowas
Und jetzt haben sie das irgendwie ersetzt oder nicht ersetzt
Sondern noch ergänzt
Durch so ein komisches Confluence Plugin
Was Zeit Erfassung macht
Ich hab letztens ein Ticket aufgemacht
Und dann hab ich eingestellt
Das ist ein Zeit Erfassung
Jira nicht Confluence
Heißt das zufällig Tempo
Kann sein
Ja das kann sein
Tempo
Jira kann sein
Ja
Ja das
Moment
Das ist das glaube ich ja
Wie ist das so chat
Wenn ihr euch damit schon auskennt
Zumindest hatte ich das Problem
Vielleicht liegt das auch gar nicht an dem Plugin
Customizations wieder
Ich hab ein Ticket aufgemacht
Und als Ticket Typ hab ich dann ausgewählt
Zeit
Zeit Erfassungs Ding
Ticket Typ
Ich weiß nicht wie das jetzt heißt
Hab ich ausgewählt
Und das ist dafür gedacht
Ich hab euch ja schon erzählt
Dass ich das mit koordiniere
Dass wir einmal im Monat
Updates auf allen
Servern machen und neue Software
Ausrollen und sowas
Und ich hab ein Ticket aufgemacht für das aktuelle Release
Und das geht halt
Bis das Release fertig ist und dann gehts wieder von vorne los
Also hab ich ein Ticket aufgemacht
Wo alle die daran beteiligt sind
Ihre Zeiten ordentlich drauf buchen können
Mit Tätigkeiten
Also hab ich das Ticket aufgemacht
Und vor 10 Tagen
Hat Jira das Ticket einfach geschlossen
Einfach so
Normalerweise schließt man das Ticket selbst
Und dann hab ich nachgeguckt
Und dann stand sowas unten drunter wie
Jira Service has closed
Jira Service
hat das Ticket abgenommen
Hä? Warum?
Dann hab ich mal bei den Atlassian Leuten
Bei den Atlassian Experten
Die wir da haben nachgefragt
Die haben gemeint, ja das muss so sein
Zeit Erfassungs Ticket werden
immer am Ende des Monats geschlossen
Aber
Das Release ist nicht am Ende des Monats fertig
Ja dann soll ich kein Zeit Erfassungs Ticket verwenden
Und dann hab ich mir gedacht okay warum haben wir denn da genau
ein Zeit Erfassungs Plugin wenn ich für das was ich
das erfassen will kein Zeit Erfassungs
Ding verwenden kann
Konnte mir dann auch keiner so genau erklären
Aber jetzt noch viel besser
Weil wir
Jetzt werden alle IT Leute schreien
Noch viel besser weil wir keinen anderen passenden
Ticket Typ haben mache ich jetzt einen
Change Request bei uns auf
Als Zeit Erfassungs Ticket für das aktuelle
Release
Gibt keinen anderen passenden
Ticket Typ
Aber hey
Ich hab es mir nicht ausgedacht
Ich benutze die Tools die mir zur Verfügung
gestellt werden ja
Und wenn die Tools scheiße sind dann kann ich sie halt auch nur
Scheiße benutzen
Ich glaube auch
Das ist ein Problem von uns ist
Nicht von diesem Plugin
Wenn ihr sagt
Ihr kennt das auch
Du benutzt das halt falsch
Ich benutze es nicht falsch und das ist falsch konfiguriert
Bei uns höchstwahrscheinlich
Wahrscheinlich kennt ihr das auch
Dass wenn man Produkte einkauft
Dass sie dann nach kurzer Zeit so stark
Customized sind dass sie eigentlich
Mit der ursprünglichen Anwendungsthematik
Für die das Produkt gedacht ist
Gar nichts zu tun
Also komplett anders umgestrickt sind
Und eigentlich gar nicht mehr so funktionieren
Wie gedacht
Ich glaube das machen alle gerne
Warum bucht ihr nicht per normalen
Tickets anstatt alles auf eins
Weil das nicht bei allen Sachen geht
Es gibt für manche
Es gibt für manche Sachen schlicht und ergreifend kein Ticket
Wenn jetzt irgendjemand
Nachts da sitzt
Und auf den Deploy Knopf drückt
Und eine halbe Stunde zuschaut wie der Deploy Balken
Sich von links nach rechts bewegt
Da gibt es da kein extra Ticket für
Da kann er das da drauf machen
Oder wenn
Keine Ahnung
Ich irgendjemand anrufe und sage
Guck mal hier die Kiste ist abgekackt
Oder keine Ahnung
Der Fileserver geht nicht mehr
Seitdem wir das letzte Mal die Konfig geupdatet haben
Der lockt sich da 20 Minuten drauf ein
Und macht das wieder ganz
Da gibt es dann auch meistens kein Ticket für
Das kann man sicherlich alles schön in der Hand haben
Das setzt aber
Das passende Umfeld voraus
Das gibt es bei uns nicht
Generell muss man sagen diese ganzen Workflow Geschichten
Die hören sich meistens in der Theorie
Immer extrem gut an
Aber praktisch scheitern sie oftmals schon
An den ersten Versuchen dann
Aber ich glaube das liegt auch
Irgendwie an uns
Weil wir die Sachen
Immer anders machen
Obwohl wir eigentlich sagen wir wollen so richtig machen
Das ist so eine
Eigenheit
Die mir auch bei dem Unternehmen wo ich arbeite
Ein bisschen auf den Sack geht
Wir sagen immer wir wollen besser werden
Und
Wir wollen das jetzt einheitlicher machen
Best Practice befolgen
Und bla bla bla
Und das sagt man dann
Und beschließt man dann auch
Und wird ganz groß angekündigt
Und sobald das Ganze dann umgesetzt wird
Schon in der ersten Woche der Umsetzung
Wird dann gesagt ach ne Moment
Das machen wir jetzt doch nicht so
Irgendein VIP Benutzer möchte das nicht
Und da denke ich mir immer Alter
Auf die Idee dass ein VIP Benutzer das nicht kommen könnte
Ist man in der Planung nicht gekommen oder wie
Und da muss man halt mal in dem Fall
Wenn man sich wirklich drauf festgelegt hat
Dann muss man halt im Zweifelsfall auch mal
Den VIP Benutzer sagen
Dass es nicht geht
Und wenn das nicht möglich ist was ja auch okay ist
Dann muss man das anders planen
So
Man kann nicht immer sagen
Jawoll wir machen das jetzt gehts ab
Und dann bei dem ersten Kontakt mit der Realität
Den Schwanz einziehen und sagen ach ne geht doch nicht
Übrigens die geilste
Die geilste Story überhaupt was es dazu gibt
Bei uns ist folgendes gewesen
Wir haben mal eine Umfrage
Durchgeführt da wusste
Das ist zu geil
Wir haben mal ne Umfrage ich wechsle mal auf den Chat
Leute ich verspreche euch wir machen gleich
Wir machen gleich
Aber das muss ich euch jetzt mal erzählen
Also wir haben mal ne Umfrage
Durchgeführt
Also es war so ne Mitarbeiter Umfrage
Es kann sogar sein dass das
Gesetzlich vorgeschrieben war ich weiß es gar nicht
Zumindest
Wir haben ne Mitarbeiter Umfrage
Durchgeführt da waren dann so Sachen drin wie
Wie stressig ist es auf der Arbeit
Wie gefällt es einem auf der Arbeit
Im Endeffekt ja also sprich
Wie stressig ist es wie sieht man
Die Work-Life Balance
Wie sieht man sein Vorgesetzte
Das war so ne 25 Fragen Umfrage
Die wurde auch von irgendeinem unabhängigen
Berater Dude
Mit keine Ahnung
800.000 Euro
Jahresgeld oder so
Durchgeführt
Das war von irgendeiner Firma
Darauf spezialisieren das fragt mich nicht
So da wurde ne Umfrage durchgeführt
Und dann irgendwann
Es hat schon länger gedauert als gedacht
Das Ergebnis ja
Und irgendwann kam das Ergebnis raus
Jetzt passt mal auf
Wie sie sich das Ergebnis
Schön gerechnet haben als erstes
Gab es ne Präsentation
Wo festgestellt wurde
Das
Ich versuch das jetzt mal so
Mehr oder weniger zu zitieren
Da steht dann da der Chef
Von dieser Abteilung
Die das quasi angeleitet haben
Das durchgeführt werden und sagt
Und jetzt irgendwie
Präsentieren wir die Ergebnisse
Und wer hätte es auch anders erwartet
Ein sehr gutes Ergebnis
Da hab ich mir schon gedacht okay wenn das
Wenn das so anfängt weiß man schon
Da kommt nix gescheites bei raus
Und
Dann ging es weiter
Da hat er seine Präsentation
Aufgemacht
Und dann hat man gesehen
Unsere Zahlen
Unsere Zahlen zu
Naja
Vergleichzahlen
So und da sahen wir halt extrem
Gut aus
Aber unsere Ergebnisse waren gar nicht so gut
Ja also wenn man jetzt mal von aus geht
Dass wir, dass man die Dinge
Bewerten konnte von 1 bis 6
Ich weiß es nicht mehr wie man sie genau bewerten konnte
Aber gehen wir einfach mal von aus du konntest die Sachen von 1 bis 6 bewerten
Da waren dann zum Beispiel so Fragen wie
Wie zufrieden sind sie mit ihrem Vorgesetzten
Oder es waren Fragen wie
Wie zufrieden sind sie mit Arbeitsabläufen
Und sind die Anweisungen immer klar
Also ist immer klar was sie machen sollen und so
So und das wurde da zusammengefasst
So in 5 Kategorien so was wie
Führung
Innovation, Arbeitsplan
So was genau
Und dann wurden unsere Zahlen verglichen mit anderen Zahlen
Und wir hatten dort
Wo es um
Wo es um Organisation
Und so was
Und Klarheit der Aufgaben und so geht
Hatten wir glaube ich
Nicht ganz eine 4
Aber fast eine 4 irgendwie 3,8
9 oder irgendwie so was
Also ziemlich schlecht
Ziemlich schlecht und
Die Vergleichzahlen waren noch schlechter
Und habe ich mir gedacht was sind das
Für Vergleichzahlen das kann doch nie im Leben
Der Durchschnitt sein
Und ich habe dann im Nachhinein rausbekommen
Ich habe dann im Nachhinein rausbekommen
Wie
Also was diese Vergleichzahlen sind
Man hätte eigentlich
Von ausgehen müssen das sind halt Vergleichzahlen
Aus allen Umfragen die die bisher
Durchgeführt haben und man vergleicht
Dazwischen nein nein nein nein nein nein
Man hat explizit
Daten
Ich sage jetzt mal eingekauft die gut dazu
Gepasst haben Man hat sich im Prinzip
Einen Datensatz eingekauft der schlechter war
Als der eigene um das zu vergleichen
Richtig richtig
Big Brain Big Brain Time
Ist halt Kacke wenn man nicht so gut abschneidet wie man denkt
Und es dann irgendwie schön
Schön rechnen muss zumindest geht
Dann noch weiter da kommt dann
Ja gut man hat die Präsentation eh nur gemacht
Um sich um sich als wieder besonders
Toll hinzustellen und
Aber das Highlight das Highlight kam dann
Das Highlight kam dann noch
Es wurde dann erzählt
Dann haben die ganzen Abteilungsleiter
Von diesen ganzen haben dann alle erzählt und wie
Wie geil wir uns verbessern werden und
Das ist jetzt quasi
Neue Qualitätsoffensiven
Gestartet werden Blabla
Also mir persönlich war schon klar Blabla
Blabla Blabla Blabla
So und also
Man hat ganz groß erzählt dass man da jetzt wirklich
Draus so
Das jetzt ein richtig gutes Fazit draus zieht
Und sich da wirklich verbessern will und sonst wie
Und
Nach einem halben Jahr
Hab ich mir dann so gedacht
Okay irgendwie habe ich
Da nie wieder was von gehört danach
Nach dieser Präsentation
Und ich
Hab dann mal
Bei dem
Was wir überlegen
Ich glaube das war der damalige Abteilungsleiter
Also das ist so bei uns kannst du manchmal
Wenn du dich anmeldest
Kannst du auf so eine
Rücksprachenrunde gehen
Und ich hab dann mal gefragt
Was ist da eigentlich draus geworden
Aus dieser Präsentation und dass wir uns jetzt so
Krass verbessern ich hab da danach nie wieder
Was von gehört
Ich hab einfach nur gegibt es da irgendwas Neues
Und da war die Antwort
Da war die Antwort
Man hat seine
Fast mehr oder weniger Zitat
Man hat seine Lehren daraus gezogen und man
Wisse um unsere Schwäche
Okay
Was
Was genau
Ich mein
Rhetorisch sehr gut gewählte Antwort
Aber null Aussagekraft
Man wisse um unsere Schwäche
Naja
Das machen wir halt laufend
So Dinger machen wir halt laufend
Wir wollen uns verbessern
Dazu wüsste man ja auch was
Dann lassen wir es besser
Aber gut
Ich sag es ja immer wieder
Jedes Unternehmen
Die kochen alle nur mit Wasser
Google, Microsoft, Apple
Wer auch immer
Epic Games
Die kochen alle nur mit Wasser
Das sieht immer so toll aus von außen
Aber letztendlich ist es
Auch nur ganz normale Leute
Naja
Gucken wir mal weiter
Aber das hat sich bei mir eingebrannt
Wir wissen um unsere Schwächen
Achja genau
Stimmt
Wozu das gesagt wird
Hab ich euch ja gar nicht erzählt
Eigentlich sollte es noch einen
Follow-up geben
Zu dieser Umfrage
Ja
Und das hat man halt dann auch
Mit mehr oder weniger dem gleichen Wortlaut
Man wisse um unsere Schwächen
Hat man das dann nicht mehr gemerkt
Und das hat man halt dann auch mit
Mehr oder weniger dem gleichen Wortlaut
Um unsere Schwächen hat man das
Dann nicht mehr gemacht
Wahrscheinlich weil das zu schlecht ausgefallen wäre
Oder so
Es wird viel geschwätzt
Wenn der Tag lang ist da
Ich muss aber auch ehrlich sagen
Eigentlich ist mir das vollkommen
Egal mittlerweile
Solange die ordentlich
Und pünktlich bezahlen
Ja
Und nicht mehr von mir wollen
Als ich im Arbeitsvertrag zugestimmt habe
Könnte ich machen was sie wollen
Das ist mir vollkommen egal
Ich mein natürlich wäre es in manchen
Bereichen
Angenehmer
Wenn man
Da was ändern würde
Oder sich das mehr in die Richtung bewegen würde
Wie ich das gerne hätte
Aber sie können machen was sie wollen
Ich denke mir immer
Die schaden sich ja selbst am meisten
Mit ihrem
Mit ihrer Diskrepanz
Zwischen Realität und
Und
Wunschdenken
Da schaden die sich ja selbst am meisten mit
Wenn man auf der einen Seite denkt
Man ist der geilste
Ist es aber nicht
Dann ist da ja schon ein ziemlich
Ziemlich großer
Unterschied dazwischen
Und was wozu das führt
Ist unterm Strich
Nichts unternimmt
Dass man wirklich besser wird was dann unterm Strich
Dazu führt dass die Konkurrenz besser wird
Und die abkacken also
Im Prinzip schaden die sich ja nur selbst
Mit so komischem Verhalten
Du hast halt Pech ne
Da kann ich ja nichts für
So also Nextcloud
Was kann man jetzt taggen
Nextcloud
Projektmanagement tool
Wo ist das Gantt Diagramm
Deck alles klar
Download alles klar machen wir
Next
Starten wir das ganze mal
Gantt Diagramm
Hey Gantt Diagramm ist doch das beste
Leute wer mag von euch
Wollt ihr sagen ihr mögt kein
Gantt Diagramm
Kann ich euch nicht
Cringe Leute Cringe Chat
Kann ich euch nicht mehr ernst nehmen
Cringe Chat
Gantt bestimmt nicht genau
Ich hab das doch bestimmt noch hier
Nextcloud
Guck mal da
Was ist das
Was hat man da
Run Network Host Nextcloud
Was hab ich denn da gemacht
Ich muss die Version mit angeben sonst funktioniert das ganze doch gar nicht
Kann ich nicht einfach sagen
Run Nextcloud
Nee
Latest ist vielleicht eine Beta Version
Ich muss ihnen den Tag machen
Kannst du das von Hand machen
Die Night
Wollt man nicht einfach 22
Alter ich will einfach die Versionsnummer kopieren ey
Oder was Doppelpunkt
Was Doppelpunkt 22
Ah Doppelpunkt 22
Stimmt hab ich vergessen war Doppelpunkt
Excellent
Latest ist immer stable
Das wäre jetzt aber
Was neues
Latest ist also gut
Vielleicht bei Nextcloud
Aber normalerweise nicht
Wie ist das jetzt abgekackt
Oder was
Warum
Ich habe aber nicht Minus D gemacht
Warum ist das jetzt abgekackt
Wo ist das Problem
Ok
Docker run
Dann machen wir es halt so wie die das schreiben
Machen wir es halt genauso wie die das schreiben
Nee Detach
Detach will ich nicht
Nein nein das ist 21
Siehste ich wusste genau
Ich wusste schon warum ich das eben nicht gemacht hab
Nextcloud hat sich bei Onlyoffice aufgehängt
Ok nice
Vollgas oder auch nicht
Falsche Version
Was die haben einen stable tag ernsthaft
Huge
Oh die haben einen stable tag
Stable tag
Stable apache
Oder gehts jetzt doch
Nee der shuttet down
Warum shuttet der denn down
Es geht schon mal gut los
Startet erst gar nicht
Vielleicht starte ich die vm einfach mal
Wobei ich hab die gerade neu gestartet
Genau das gleiche
Hab ich die Festplatte voll
Warum geht das jetzt nicht
Das fängt ja schon wieder gut an
Wo ist das Problem
Ok dann detache ich mal
Aber das sollte eigentlich keinen Unterschied machen
Man muss sich mehr zugucken können
Ok
Localhost port 80 müsste sein
Denn ich hab
Come on firefox
Ok manchmal ist firefox nervig
Normalerweise geht das auch
Wir haben das schon ein paar mal per docker probiert
Ah da sind wir doch
Man muss anscheinend detachen sonst mag er das nicht
Man muss
Man muss anscheinend detachen
Ok
Kennt ihr mal eine bessere Lösung für Bilder Kollaboration
Nein
Ich weiß nur dass die Bilder App
Die Foto App in nextcloud ziemlicher Müll ist
So Admin 1,2,3,4,5,6
Oh Mist Leute
Leaked
Das ist version
20? Nee warum
Ich hoffe nicht, 20 wirklich, warum ist das 20, stable ist 20, ok, warum?
beta ist 22, nee das ist rausgekommen vor vor zehn tagen oder so
ok muss ich jetzt muss ich jetzt nicht nicht wirklich verstehen
nee gut dann nehmen wir halt den hier naja oh please nehmen wir halt keine ahnung apache gibt
es den nimmer 22 22 00 apache wobei doch ich habe es doch richtig gemacht ach das ist jetzt
latest ok das ist eine komische versionierung die beta 22 ist raus nee das ding ist wirklich
wirklich, das ist doch erschienen hier, genau, das ist doch erschienen, da machen wir eben
doch Latest, meinetwegen, Latest, das besser funktioniert, ne, bei Pandora Container muss
kein Hub dabei schreiben, hier schauen wir mal jetzt, ob es jetzt funktioniert, ok geht,
Admin 123456, ist das denn jetzt auch 22, sehen wir gleich, der Latest Tag, es kommt aufs
Projekt an, der Latest Tag ist oftmals direkt Githat, also je nachdem was für Builds die machen,
deswegen würde ich nie empfehlen Latest irgendwo reinzuschreiben, sondern eher die richtigen
Versions Tag, oder am besten, falls die sowas haben, den Major Versions Tag, Passwort League,
ja, MonkaS, also was installiert er, Kalender, Kontakt, Talk, Mail, Collaborative Editing,
ok, mach, passt, alles gut, Finish, das müsste jetzt, das müsste jetzt 22 sein, ist das jetzt
22, müsste jetzt eigentlich 22 sein, sehen wir gleich, ob das 22 ist, MonkaS, geh weg,
so, wo sieht man die Versionsnummer, Help, Admin Settings, so, irgendwo hier müsste eigentlich
die Versionsnummer jetzt stehen, ne, 21, what, warum ist das jetzt, Alter, was ist das wieder
schon für ne komische Versionierung, ok, ich schreib dir jetzt Hardcoded 22 hin, und jetzt
hat es gefällig zu funktionieren, so, jetzt nochmal, wenn das jetzt nicht 22 ist, obwohl
ich fest den Versions Tag 22 gehöre, very weak Passwort, woher wollen die das wissen,
mein Passwort steht doch gar nicht da, das ist kein weak Passwort, also ist best practiced
mein Passwort, das ist das meist benutzte Passwort der Welt, das kann nicht schlecht
sein, so, start, jawoll, ok, und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt die richtige Version
ist, Settings, Overview 22, ok, perfekt, SQL is slide being used as database backend, ja,
das ist absichtlich, für eine Person soll es ja wohl ausreichen, für was steht das
ZZZ Eigen Open in der Leiste, das ist da CPU Auslastung, guck, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel,
zum Beispiel, machen wir mal irgendwas, irgendwas, was viel CPU Last verursacht, äh, Echo, guck,
jetzt ist ein CPU Kern komplett ausgelastet, weil der jetzt rechnet, 2 hoch, 2 hoch, äh,
22 Millionen, das ist aber ganz schön langsam, oder, 2 hoch, 22 Millionen, jetzt erwartet,
warum braucht der denn dafür so lang, mal gucken, wie schnell Google ist, langsam, ok,
mal gucken, wie schnell ist der Win aus Taschenrechner, Invalid, Invalid Import, ok, Win aus Taschenrechner,
2 hoch, 2, ach nee, da, Moment, Moment, Scientific, Scientific, 2 hoch, stimmt das, gleich, äh,
warum, 2 hoch, das kann er, ok, die Zahl ist zu groß, das mag er nicht, muss ich gar nicht,
dass, dass man, Echo, das ist schon eine ziemlich große Zahl, ja, mal gucken, ob Google das
ausrechnen kann, 2 hoch, 2 kann Google ausrechnen, so, 2 hoch, 22.000, nee, das können sie schon
nicht, ok, ok, wusste ich nicht, wie löscht man den Kram hier um, 2 hoch, ist es das,
ok, Infinity, alles klar, ich wusste schon immer, 2 hoch, 22.000 ist unendlich, war mir
schon immer klar, ja, ich glaube, da würde mir jetzt, so ziemlich jeder Mathe-Man widersprechen,
Wolfram Alpha, genau, das probieren wir mal aus, die probieren wir mal aus, 2 hoch, so,
so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so,
so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, 2 hoch, ok, jetzt годet ein bisschen
es ein bisschen, 5 hoch, okay, 2 hoch, oder, das ist der der, oder, das ist der, und, ja,
mit 6,7 Millionen Nullen. Okay, das ist doch tatsächlich relativ lang.
Das ist ziemlich, das ist ziemlich viel. Okay, dann ist kein Wunder, dass der nicht
fertig wird. Ich mein guck mal allein schon sowas dauert
wahrscheinlich ja. Das sind jetzt 68.000 Stellen, okay.
Ja, das ist halt okay, die Zahl ist größer, als ich das gedacht habe, aber ja gut, jetzt
haben wir die unwichtigen Sachen jetzt durch. Also weiter, weiter zu Nextcloud.
Talk Updates. Okay, kann man den, kann man diesen Krempel
hier auspletten? Das brauch ich nicht.
Talk weg. Wetter, Alter, wer hat denn, hat irgendjemand
nach ner fucking Wetter-App in Nextcloud gefragt? Ich hab das Gefühl, jeder, der nicht weiß,
was er machen soll, baut ne Wetter-App. To do list Poggers. Ja, das probieren wir jetzt
mal aus, also. Versuch hier mal ranzuzoomen, ob das verkraftet.
Set Wetter-Location. Okay, mache ich. Detect Location. Allow. Gucken.
Kommt hin. Ne, das Wetter stimmt aber hinten vorne
nicht für Hanau. Schon wieder liegt, fuck. So 500 Mal, dass
ich in Hanau wohne geliegt. Shit.
Aber das Wetter stimmt nicht. Das Wetter stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das ist Sonnenschein gerade. Das ist nicht rainy.
Das ist auch nicht 12 AM, ja, das stimmt. Es ist 19.52, na gut.
Ja, mit Postleitzahl steht immer dabei. Aber die Postleitzahl, aber Hanau hat mehrere
Postleitzahlen. So, also, wie gehts da weiter? Product-Plan.
Ah, yes. Alles klar.
Gut, also, was probieren wir jetzt mal aus? Als erstes möchte ich mal testen, ob so,
okay, Mail-App kann ich jetzt, glaube ich, nicht ausprobieren, weil ich kennt irgendjemanden
einen IMAP-Server, den man kostenlos zum Testen verwenden kann.
Oder gibt es irgendeinen fertigen IMAP-Docker-Container, den man verwenden kann?
Docker-Mail-Server, da guck mal da. Full-Stack. Ich hätte gerne einfach irgendwas zum Starten
und gut ist, ich will nicht 130, nein, das ist mir viel zu viel.
Hey, ich will irgendwas Lokales haben. Gut, das können wir dann später mal gucken.
Also, wie ist die Kalender-App mittlerweile? Taugt die? Taugt die? Taugt die? Okay, sieht
im Prinzip noch genauso aus wie vorher. 0W, ja, okay, es crasht nicht mehr, wenn man
das raus-trackt. Ich bin schon mal begeistert.
Hack-Länder. Ah, das geht immer noch nicht. Geht immer noch nicht. Hätte ich jetzt eigentlich
erwartet, dass es mittlerweile funktioniert, dass man Termine zwischen Kalendern verschieben
kann, aber es funktioniert nicht. Ach nee, ich habe das Konzept falsch verstanden.
Das ist alles in einem Kalender und man kann ein- und ausplänen. Okay, okay. Dann habe
ich das letzte Mal, glaube ich, auch falsch verstanden. So kann man das auswählen. Das
heißt, wenn ich die Kategorie ändern will, muss ich da wahrscheinlich drauf und kann
es so verschieben. Na gut, aber dann hätten wir es auch machen können, dass ich es so
verschieben kann. Fake SMTP-Service. Nee, ich brauche kein Fake SMTP. Ich brauche einen
Fake- ich brauche einen Fake- Fake IMAP. Ah. Nee, Moment. Warte. Okay. Tanja Rohe, alles
klar. Oh, League. Okay, dann verwende ich das jetzt nicht. Bam. Continue. Antoinett Dick.
Alter, was ist das denn? Ich will nicht Antoinett Dick heißen. So, dann schauen wir uns die
To-Do-App an. Wo ist die To-Do-App? Die war nämlich auch crap das letzte Mal. Haben
die endlich einen vernünftigen E-Mail-Klient hinbekommen? Ich vermute nicht. Ich habe
aber gerade- Oh doch, ich teste jetzt den E-Mail-Klient. Leute, ich blende euch mal
kurz aus. Ich will jetzt nämlich- also, das ist nicht schlimm, das ist eine anonyme E-Mail-Adresse,
das ist eh egal, aber was ich nicht will ist, dass irgendwelche Dickpicks geschickt werden
oder so, die ich aus versehenem Stream zeige. Weiß man ja nie hier. Weiß man ja nie. Katschi
Buzz, genau. Okay, dann probieren wir uns jetzt mal E-Mail aus. Mein E-Mail-Adresse, E-Mail-Adresse
ist Margot Kupal Israel Mail Passwort. Moment, ist das Klartext? Nee. Connect. Ah, hat funktioniert.
Interessant. Oh Mist, jetzt ist die E-Mail-Adresse ja doch geleakt. Okay, das ist das nächste
Problem. Ich gehe jetzt raus, bevor mir Leute irgendwelche komischen Mails schicken. Wie
kriege ich die E-Mail-Adresse wieder weg? Wie die registriere ich die E-Mail-Adresse
wieder? Remove. Okay. Ich zeige euch jetzt einfach, ich zeige euch jetzt einfach die
E-Mail-Adresse nicht. Chat wird ausgesperrt. Ich hoffe, das funktioniert. Leak in 3, 2,
1. Mal gucken. Da muss ich erstmal set-upen wieder. Äh nee, ich blende das neben aus,
falls das funktioniert. Ah, das geht nicht. Ah, pass mal auf, wir machen einen Big Brain
Move. Massive Brain Move, null. Okay, bam. Sack. Ja. Okay.
Echt, habe ich schon wieder geleakt? Nee, habe ich nicht geleakt, der ist jetzt geleakt.
Okay. Write Message. Boah, ist das lahm, das Ding. Ach, scheiß auf Leak. New Message, hallo.
Next Cloud, please. Ah, hier. So, was auch wichtig ist, ich muss einstellen können,
dass er kein HTML lädt. Geht wieder nicht, oder? Geht immer noch nicht. Kann man Settings?
Kann ich an mich selbst eine E-Mail schreiben? Rot, nee. Rot. Okay, kein Autocomplete. Hallo?
Warum ist das so pro, diese Mail-App? So, Mail. Mail-Settings hier. What? Ach so, man muss
da rein. Hallo? Inbox, oh nee, oh nee, die Dickpicks kommen. Fuck. Geh weg. Jemand hat
mich für den Netto-Discounter angemeldet. Okay, das ist blöd, das muss ich euch zeigen,
die E-Mail-App ist komplett broken. Guckt euch das an. Die E-Mail-App ist komplett broken.
Deswegen will ich das nicht in HTML anzeigen. Ich will das anzeigen in Text. Das kann man
nämlich nicht, ne? Das bilde ich mir nämlich, als ich das letzte Mal schon gesucht habe
und ich gefunden habe. Standardmäßig HTML ist fail. Allow app to collect data? Nee.
Ist ja. Okay, die E-Mail-App sackt immer noch hart. Okay, die E-Mail-App ist immer noch
nicht zu gebrauchen. Ja, exellente Newsletter hier. Gut, die kann's komplett knicken. Das
ist der Versuch, eine E-Mail-App in X-Cloud einzubauen. Kann's vergessen. Komplett unbenutzbar.
Aufruf-Account. Bam. Und Tschüss. Recommendate-Tasks, genau. Notes, probieren wir aus, also die
üblichen Geschichten. Notes und To-Do's. Was ich übrigens immer noch dumm finde, dass
Tasks und Notes nicht die gleiche App sind. Warum kriege ich eine App empfohlen, die untestet
ist? Unmerkwürdig. Social. Ja, unbedingt. Ich finde es geil, dass sie mir offiziell
eine App zum installieren vorschlagen, die untestet ist. Letztendlich, die Dinger sind
alle untestet, weil sie zum größten Teil crappy sind. So, also was haben wir jetzt hier?
Kalender, Notes, Deck. Wo ist mein To-Do hin? Ich hab doch eben auch Dings installiert, oder?
Tasks. Ach so. Okay, jetzt muss ich erst nochmal downloaden. Okay, Tasks. Okay, Tasks. Okay,
Tasks. Der Kekländer ist immer noch da. Also, KekW1, KekW2, KekW3. Genau, also das ist immer
noch die most basic To-Do-App aller Zeiten, aber zumindest kackt sie nicht mehr ab, wenn
man Sachen auf die Leiste track und dropt. Das ist schon mal gut. Ansonsten ist das so
ziemlich die rudimentärste To-Do-App, die ihr euch irgendwie vorstellen könnt. Nix
dolles, nichts außergewöhnliches, aber es funktioniert. Das einzige Problem ist, dass
es keine gescheite To-Do-App-Integration gibt in irgendwelche Clients. Also, das sind
Call of To-Do's, was glaube ich außer Thunderbird und ein paar andere nicht unterstützen. iOS
kann es, iOS kann es. Und die wollen es auch nicht mehr länger können, weil sie glaubt
schon vor zwei iOS Versionen versucht haben, alles Call of Mäßige rauszuschmeißen, was
nicht Apple ist und die Leute sich dann aufgeregt haben und jetzt ist es immer noch drin. Also,
es geht immer noch, aber die wollen es loswerden. Android geht, aber Android geht nur mit Zusatz.
Es gibt aber wenige. Gerade auf dem Desktop gibt es sehr, sehr wenige ordentliche Call
of Clients. Es gibt eigentlich, Cross-Platform gibt es eigentlich erwähnenswert nur Thunderbird,
das ist aber auch mehr schlecht als recht. Und da gibt es noch M-Client, E-M-Client,
für Windows der ist ganz okay, für Linux wird mir jetzt gar nichts einfallen und für
Mac gibt es bestimmt ein paar. Ja, ist halt Lul. Es ist halt eine To-Do-App. Die ganz
okay ist übrigens. Ach ja, Moment, geht die Suche denn jetzt? 1, 2, 3. Ja, Gott sei Dank,
die Suche funktioniert wenigstens mittlerweile. Das ging nämlich auch lange Zeit nicht. Man
kann jetzt nach Tasks suchen. Man würde ja eigentlich erwarten so eine Basic Funktion
geht schon seit 10 Jahren, aber nein, nein, nein, nein. Das geht erst seit ein paar Versionen
oder seit erst dieser Version, weiß ich gar nicht. Es ist auf jeden Fall neu. Es ist auf
jeden Fall neu. Das funktioniert. Okay, okay. Es ist immer, es ist ein bisschen langsam,
okay. Next Cloud war noch nie dafür bekannt, jetzt irgendwie die Ausgeburt der Geschwindigkeit
zu sein. Ich meine, das ist ein Quad-Core, ein Quad-Core 8700K, also der soll jetzt eigentlich
schon halbwegs geschwind. Was wäre eine Alternative zu CalDAF? Tja, CalDAF ist auf marktsteigenden
Ast. Es gibt immer weniger, was es unterstützt, beziehungsweise immer mehr, wo die Hersteller
keinen Bock mehr haben, das zu pflegen. Leider an offenen Alternativen nicht allzu viel.
Du hast Outlook und Active Sync und dieses Microsoft Geschiss und du hast die ganzen
proprietären Sachen von Evernote bis Google, Gedöns und sonst was. So eine wirkliche offene
Geschichte wie CalDAF gibt es eigentlich keine zweite. So, man kann sogar alle, alles schließen
Leute, alles schließen. So, alle To Do's abgearbeitet. Exzellent. Gut, das funktioniert brauchbar
muss ich sagen. Ok, das ist langsamer. Jetzt gehts schneller. Ja, ist in Ordnung. Also
die To Do App ist jetzt benutzbar, aber echt nichts besonderes. Welche To Do App benutzt
ihr auf der Arbeit? Ich benutze gar keine, ich benutze mein Handy ab und zu mal. Ich
habe eh, also ich mache ja hauptsächlich aktuell Dauer Home Office. Ich verwende eigentlich
hauptsächlich das hier, schon seit ein paar Jahren. Es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt die Augenweite
und es ist jetzt vielleicht auch nicht das Performance Wunder und die Mobile Apps ist
jetzt auch nicht so das Allergeilste, aber es ist in Kombination noch das Beste, was
ich bisher gefunden habe, wenn man das selbst gehostet machen will.
Ja, die proprietären Sachen, sowas. Ich gehe mal davon aus, ich habe übrigens Evernote
nie verwendet, muss ich dazu sagen. Ich kenne das von Felix, aber ich glaube, da werden
auch in nächster Zeit keine freien Tools rankommen. Ich meine, es macht halt einen Unterschied,
ob du ein Entwicklerteam da sitzen hast, wo sich dann 50 Mann den ganzen Tag, gut, wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen viel jetzt, den ganzen Tag um sowas kümmern und ein paar Leute, die das
hobbymäßig machen. Die vertreten dann natürlich auch nicht die Interessen der User im Sinne
des, äh, Aussicht des Users, sondern nur so weit wie nötig, dass ihnen die User nicht
wegrennen. Also sowas wie Evernote zum Beispiel. Es ist alles echt nicht der Weisheitsletzter
Schluss. Deswegen kann ich auch jeden Casual-Anwender verstehen, der sagt, ja warum, ich mache einfach
Google Sync und gut ist. Ja, ich synke das Joplin Zeug in Nextcloud. Ich bin halt überhaupt
nicht glücklich mit Nextcloud an sich. Das Gute an Joplin ist, das hat, also das ist
der Grund, warum ich es eigentlich ursprünglich mal verwendet habe. Das hat einen Windows Client,
das hat einen Mac Client, das hat einen Linux Client, das hat einen Android Client und
das hat einen iOS Client. Also außer Mac Client, diese vier Dinger will ich haben. Ich will
Linux, Windows, Android und iOS Client haben und die unterstützen To Do's und die jeweiligen
Notifications auf der Plattform. Das heißt, ich bekomme dann auch Benachrichtigungen,
wenn was ist. Dafür ist es wirklich gut. Wenn man Termine und Kalender sharen will, ist das
natürlich wieder nichts. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass sie den Server haben. Ich wusste wirklich
nicht, dass sie den Server haben. Den gibt es wohl auch nur nicht so lange, weil ich
verwende das, wie gesagt, ich verwende das seit Jahren schon und ich wusste nicht, dass
sie das haben. Wo gibt es denn den Server? Sehe ich hier nur Prerelease? Hier? Ah. Ja,
ganz ehrlich, da mache ich es lieber damit, als dass ich da für einen Web-DAF Nextcloud
hinstelle. Gut, aber das ist wirklich ganz nice. Gut, weiter. Nextcloud. Also festgestellt,
die To Do App, wo habe ich es denn jetzt hier überhaupt? Ach, da. Die To Do App scheint
mir halbwegs brauchbar. E-Mail ausblenden. Bäm. Wetter ausblenden. Status ausblenden.
Wobei Status. Upcoming Cards. Notes. Upcoming Cards ist für uns, ist für die Business-Leute
hier. Cute Chat. Ah, ja, ja. Open Card. Oh, jetzt kann ich meine Kanban, meine Kanban,
mein Kanbanfetisch ausleben hier. Massive. Da habe ich drauf gewartet. Mit dem rudimentärsten
Kanbanbord aller Zeiten wahrscheinlich. Und man braucht da nicht viel. Ich finde halt,
die eingebauten Apps, die sind jetzt alle keine Augenweide. Aber hey, solange sie funktionieren,
ist in Ordnung. Stimmt, Dark Mode müssen wir noch einschalten. Wo ist der Dark Mode?
Ich hasse übrigens, und das muss ich, da muss ich mich immer aufregen, ich hasse es, wenn
Webseiten Control-F hijacken. Control-F soll gefälligst diese Suche sein. Guck, damit
hätte ich es nämlich gefunden mit Control-F. Ich hasse es, wenn Control-F gehijackt wird.
Wirklich, das ist das Schlimmste. Und wie mache ich jetzt, wie mache ich hier mein
Dark Steam jetzt? Ne, das ist was anderes. Next Cloud Dark Steam. Ist unter Accessibility.
Ja, wer hätte auch damit Recht? Also Moment, das ergibt tatsächlich Sinn. Das ergibt Sinn,
dass es nicht unter Seaming ist. Seaming ist Administration Cloud-wide und das ist Personal
Info. Das macht Sinn. Ich habe einfach einen Docker-Container gestartet. Okay, Dark Steam,
das ist für, was ist das nochmal? Lese, Rechtschreib, Schwäche oder sowas? Dislexia. Was ist dyslexia?
Unter dyslexia versteht man eine Werkzeugstörung, weil er trotz normalen Seh- und Hörvermögen
die fähig geeigneten Wörter und Texte lesen zu verstehen. Und da bringt so eine Schrift was?
Okay. Was genau bringt, das würde mich jetzt echt mal interessieren. Was bringt, also wenn
man Probleme hat, Wörter und Texte zu verstehen, inwieweit hilft einem so eine Schrift denn dann?
Was macht diese Schrift anders als die normale Schrift, dass man das nicht versteht und
das dann versteht? Aha. Okay. Was hast du mal? Was gelernt, wusste ich nicht. High Contrast Mode.
Ah ja. Das ist ja, keine Ahnung von. Das ist ja wieder Massive Big Brain Chat. Sache. Einziger
Stream auf Glitch hier, wo man was lernt. So. Jetzt haben wir Set Status. Übrigens,
soll ich euch mal den Teams Hack, den Microsoft Teams Hack, den besten Teams Hack aller Zeiten
erzählen. Microsoft Teams Busy State. Ihr müsst euch in Teams immer auf beschäftigt stellen,
weil beschäftigt und im Telefonat haben den gleichen Status, das gleiche Status icon. Also
wenn ihr euch auf beschäftigt stellt, dann denken alle, ihr würdet telefonieren. Das heißt,
wenn ihr eure Ruhe haben wollt, stellt euch nicht auf nicht stören. Nicht stören ist doof,
weil nicht stören heißt im Endeffekt, die Leute schreiben euch trotzdem an. Der Text wird nur
angezeigt, wenn du drüber gehst. Der Text steht standardmäßig nicht dabei. Der wird nur angezeigt,
wenn du drüber gehst oder wenn du Chat Fenster aufmachst. Wenn du neben deine Kontaktliste hast. Guck,
wenn du hier neben die Kontaktliste hast, da steht das nicht. Die Leute gucken auf das rote
Icon und wenn du ein rotes Icon hast, denken die, du bist am Telefonieren. Appear offline. Ich
glaube, das kann man bei uns nicht einstellen. Viel einfacher ist ein Meet-Sein mit sich selbst
zu starten. Leute, hier Big Brain Time Team-Tipps heute. Ja, Meeting mit sich selbst starten geht
ja mittlerweile einfach in Teams. Du gehst einfach in deinen Kalender und sagst Meet Now und dann
sitzt er allein in deinem Meeting-Raum rum. Eigentlich richtig sättige, oder? Ganzen Tag
alleine Meeting. Aber ist eine gute Idee. Ich glaube, das werde ich auch mal ausprobieren
nächste Woche. Wenn mich die Leute zu sehr nerven, mache ich einfach aus und setze mich
in meinen eigenen Meeting-Raum und Ruhe ist. Dann mache ich mein eigenes Daily Scrum. Fünf
Stunden. Auf Abwesenstellen ist doof. Insofern, dann sieht das so aus, als bist du den ganzen
Tag nie da. Oder, das musst du jetzt erklären, oder du trittst eine Meeting-Bahn, landest
zufällig in einer neuen Dimension. Das musst du jetzt etwas näher ausführen. Gibt's da
auch? Ja, gibt es, gibt es. Skipner-Teams-RP. Ok, Status Message. Ok, ich fahre auf die Arbeit
für 30 Minuten. Jawoll. So sieht's aus. Ich bin auf dem Weg zur Arbeit. Ich habe übrigens,
es muss ich jetzt gerade nochmal einwerfen. Ihr wisst, ich lasse mich manchmal ein bisschen
leicht sidetracken, aber das muss ich jetzt nochmal erzählen. Ich habe vor zwei Tagen,
am Donnerstag, Donnerstag, Donnerstag, habe ich mal wieder gemerkt, wie groß mittlerweile
der Unterschied ist zwischen privat versichert und gesetzlich versichert. Nur mal für alle,
die beim letzten Rant nicht dabei waren, darüber. Ich bin immer noch gesetzlich versichert.
Ich habe eigentlich auch nicht vor, das zu ändern. Aber, also ich müsste jetzt eigentlich,
also 35 sagt man so, oder maximal unter 40 ist eigentlich das, wo es sich noch irgendwie
lohnt, aber da will ich mich jetzt nicht darüber auslassen. Ich mache es aber manchmal so,
wenn es schnell gehen soll, rufe ich bei irgendeiner privaten Praxis an und sage, ey, kann
mal einer gucken, ich bezahle selbst. Da kommst du mega schnell dran. So, und ich habe es
wieder am Donnerstag gemerkt, ich habe schon ewig einen Hausarzt, einen Hautarzttermin
wollte ich machen und da habe ich beim Hautarzt angerufen in Frankfurt und habe gesagt, ja,
da müsste man mal gucken und sonst und dann hat die, nicht deswegen, aber Vorsorge ist
wichtig in der Richtung. Habe ich da angerufen und habe gesagt, wie sieht es aus? Und dann
hat die gesagt, wie sieht es bei Ihnen heute Mittag aus? Ich habe angerufen um 10, 16
Uhr hat sie Termin, gleicher Tag. So, wenn ich bei meinem Hausarzt in Hanau anrufe, hätte
der gesagt, ja, so in 4 Monaten können sie vorbeikommen. Es ist so ein riesen Unterschied
dazwischen, das ist der Wahnsinn. Und dann werden immer noch Diskussionen geführt so
nach dem Motto, wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir keine 2 Klassenmedizin kriegen, bla bla
bla, der haben wir ja schon, ist ja da. Und ich muss sagen, vom grundsätzlichen Ansatz
her, dass wenn einer quasi sehr viel Geld hat, dass der sich quasi auch besonders extravagant
behandeln lassen kann. Okay, habe ich kein Problem mit, aber das Niveau für gesetzlich
versicherte sollte aber besser sein, als es jetzt ist. Kann nicht sein, dass du 4 Monate
auf den Termin warten musst, dich dann teilweise beim Arzt fühlst, als hat er gar keinen Bock,
dich anzugucken und im Zweifelsfall er auch noch Scheiße macht, weil er keinen Bock hat
und an dir nichts verdient. Also, es sind Welten, es sind Weltenunterschied dazwischen.
Bringen diese Zusatzversicherungen was, kann ich nichts sagen. Ja, ne, es ist halt echt,
es sind Welten dazwischen. Ich war jetzt schon ein paar Mal bei Ärzten, wo ich gesagt habe,
ich bezahle selbst, das war dann auch meisten Sachen, wo ich wusste, hey, das kostet jetzt
kein 500 Euro oder so. Ich glaube, das teuerste, was ich mal hatte, war glaube ich 150 Euro
oder so, aber das ist Welten und was mir aufgefallen ist, was mir aufgefallen ist, die haben mittlerweile
zwei, also es gibt ja Ärzte, die machen nur privat, es gibt Ärzte, die machen nur gesetzlich
und es gibt mittlerweile zum größten Teil, eigentlich ist es hybrid, also die, die gesetzlich
machen, die machen eigentlich alle auch noch private, logischerweise, wäre ja auch blöd
wenn nicht und da haben sie es mittlerweile so gemacht, zumindest habe ich das so erlebt,
dass die fast alle zwei Wartezimmer haben und die Wartezimmer sind so platziert, dass
die Leute sich nicht gegenseitig sehen. Ich war zum Beispiel in Frankfurt bei einem HNO-Arzt
und da haben die das Wartezimmer für Privatversicherte oder Selbstzahler, haben die quasi ein Stückchen
um die Ecke gemacht und das Wartezimmer für den Rest, das war dann, war natürlich größer
und das war so platziert, dass die sich nicht sehen und warum ist das so? Naja klar, weil
wenn dort einer eineinhalb Stunden wartet und es kommt jetzt kurz mal einer unten rein
und wird direkt durchgeschleust zum Doktor, das wollen die natürlich nicht, dass man
das sieht, da kannst du dich ja auch, kein Wunder, da würden die sich ja auch dann drüber
aufregen ja. Beim Zahnarzt, ja Chandler, beim Zahnarzt war ich auch öfters, Zahnarzt, mittlerweile
ich bin früher nie zum Zahnarzt gegangen, weil ich immer gesagt habe, ich habe Schiss
vom Zahnarzt, aber mittlerweile gehe ich immer regelmäßig zum Zahnarzt, weil es einfacher
ist regelmäßig zum Zahnarzt zu gehen und sich sagen zu lassen, es ist nichts, als selten
zum Zahnarzt zu gehen und dann jedes Mal ein Riesenakt. Deswegen, ich habe auch schon seit
ein paar Jahren nichts mehr gehabt, gar nichts mehr. In den USA übertreiben sie es ja total,
so nach dem Motto, du bist am verbluten, sind sie versichert, naja gut dann tschüss. Wobei
es glaube ich gar nicht mehr so schlimm ist, ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung, wie es aktuell
in den USA läuft, hatten die nicht auch, gab es nicht diese Obamacare Geschichte, ich
habe das wirklich nur ganz ganz am Rande mitgekriegt, wo viele in den USA ja gesagt haben, das wollen
sie nicht, wo sie gesagt haben, das wäre ja quasi irgendwie staatlich, na es haben ja
auch viele gesagt, die wollen nicht, es haben ja auch viele gesagt, das ist irgendwie quasi
so staatlich aufgezwungener Kram und da sind sie nicht dafür, es haben ja auch wirklich
viele in den USA gesagt, die wollen das nicht. Ich habe jetzt letztens Silux installiert,
ich bin Anfänger, also Ubuntu fühlt sich etwas langsam, weißt du, wie hast du es installiert
auf einer Hardware oder in der VM? In der VM ist das normal, weil Ubuntu, zumindest
die Standardvarianten, ich glaube alle offiziellen Ubuntu, nee XFCE nicht, aber ich glaube die
meisten Ubuntu Desktops, die wollen oder mögen 3D Beschleunigungen auf eine SSD, ok also
ein Dualboot, ok dann weiß ich nicht, woran das liegt, aber die Default Oberfläche von
Ubuntu ist halt auch zutiefst hässlich, nee das kann ich dir da nicht sagen, aber willkommen
in der Linux Welt, du wirst jetzt nicht mehr den größten Teil deines Lebens vom Rechner
verbringen und dich darüber aufregen, dich über Windows aufregen, du wirst jetzt die
Zeit damit verbringen, rauszubekommen, wie man Linux so konfiguriert, dass es das macht,
was du machen willst. Du hast jetzt quasi Pest gegen Cholera getauscht, nur, dass du dafür
die eine Sache wenigstens mal bezahlen musst. Snom langsamer als Windows, nee das nimmt
sich alles nicht viel. Der Vorteil ist, wenn man sich nach ein paar Jahren dann richtig
gut auskennt, das ist eine Investition, die lohnt sich für die Zukunft. Und dadurch,
wenn man Linux lernt, lernt man in der Regel auch relativ viel über die Funktionsweise
von Computern und sonst wie, also es ist auf jeden Fall gut investierter Zeit, sich mit
Linux auseinanderzusetzen. Übrigens, 2022 wird sicherlich das Jahr des Linux Desktops,
ganz bestimmt. Überlege auch, wie sie zu machen, danke deines Videos, das ist doch
nice. Okay Leute, wir müssen weiter LexCloud gucken. Mail haben wir angeguckt, Kalender
Kontakt haben wir uns angeguckt, das ist alles noch äußerst basic. Notes, Leute, Notes
waren immer richtig schlecht. Richtig schlecht. Mal gucken, ob die jetzt besser sind. New
Note. Test. Ist das Markdown? Jawoll. Oh man, eine Note. So und irgendwo rein. Hackerman.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Was macht die Suche? Ist die standardmäßig drinnen? Okay, aber zur Zeile
springen tut er natürlich nicht. Übrigens, das ist so ein Ding, was mich LexCloud ärgert
immer. Die Funktionen sind, also LexCloud, die Dinger sind immer so zu 80% fertig. Irgendjemand
hat sich mal hingesetzt und ganz gute Basis programmiert als App. Aber die werden nicht
fertig gemacht. Ich mein, warum springt das Ding nicht in die Zeile, wo es das gefunden
hat? Soll ich jetzt hier wirklich durchsuchen, wo das ist? Wo steht hier 1, 2, 3, 4, 5? Und
das Schlimme ist, ich kann hier drin noch nicht mal Steuerung F drücken, weil das Ding Steuerung
F hijackt. Das heißt, ich hab gar keine Chance 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 zu finden. Es sei denn, es sei
denn, ich gehe hier oben in die Leiste 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Mag ich nicht. F3? Ja, super. Ist
auch kacke. Control F, beste. Das ist übrigens auch mein größter Kritikpunkt an LexCloud,
dass die Sachen zum größten Teil einfach unfertig und unpolished as fuck sind. GitHub
Issue ist schon auf 100%. 1000%ig gab es da schon zig GitHub Issues, die geschlossen
werden. Das ist auch so ne Sache, die mich an LexCloud nervt. Die kümmern sich nicht
um ihre GitHub Issues. Ich hab schon viele Probleme gesehen, gelesen, Ticket gefunden
dazu und festgestellt, oh nö. Entweder ist es seit 3 Jahren offen oder seit übertrieben
seit 3 Monaten offen. 3 Jahre gibts das glaub ich noch gar nicht. Und es tut sich nix.
Ja. Was macht eigentlich die Foto App? Was macht eigentlich die Foto App? Die ist immer
noch langsam, okay. Aber das ist nicht schlimm. So, Foto App. Kann die Foto App jetzt irgendwie
Albums? Nein, kann sie nicht, oder? Also sie kann, dann geb ich jetzt Videos. Aber Albums
kann das Ding immer. Warum ist das schwarz? Ach, das ist ne, das ist ne. Wie wärs mit
nem Vorschau Thumbnail oder irgendwas für die Videos? Was hast, Beowulf, was hast du
für Tickets denn erstellt, wo dann sinnvoll geantwortet wurde oder gar, dass der Fehler
behoben wurde? Sag mal ein Beispiel, was war denn, also ich machs jetzt, ich machs jetzt
nicht auf im Stream oder so. Aber sag mal ein Beispiel, was haben die behoben innerhalb
von, oder haben das wirklich in kürzer Zeit behoben? Außer das übliche Bot-Antwort.
Guck mal, wenn man jetzt nämlich mal GitHub Issues LexCloud geht. So, und jetzt suchen
wir hier nach Fotos. Fotos weiß ich ist eins der größten Kritikpunkte, die die Leute
haben. So. Gut, das ist jetzt alles nicht so spannend. Sortieren wir mal nach Comments.
Okay, das verstehe ich. Das verstehe ich. Das ist ja auch ein Bug der Enterprise-Kunst
hat. Ich muss tatsächlich, ich muss ins Fotorepo. Falls hier. Hier ist der Knopf. Ja, das sind
dann hier Bugs teilweise. Ja, dass Face Recognition 3 Jahre auf ist, das verstehe ich ja. Album
Design, okay. Das ist ja 2 Jahren auf. So, wie macht man jetzt hier überhaupt Fotoalben?
Ich hab's schon wieder, ich check's schon wieder. Ich weiß, dass das mal früher nicht
ging. Gucken, ob das jetzt geht. Ach, ich muss in Files, ich muss in Files gehen und
da. Kann ich jetzt sagen? Fotos 2 oder so? Fotos 2. Ich bin übrigens unfähig, ich weiß
gar nicht, wie man das umschiebt. Wie schiebt man den Kram? Move or copy? Zu. Fotos 2. Exzellent.
Okay, das checkt ja alles gut. Ja, meine Sonderlich-Komfortabler-Funktion ist nicht,
aber es scheint halbwegs zu tun. Na ja. Gut, ich brauch eh keine Fotos-App, aber ich weiß,
dass die Foto-App eben das Ding ist, was ganz viele Leute verwenden. Du kannst Fotos auch
taggen, huge. Man müsste jetzt mal den aktuellen Desktop-Client installieren. Max-Cloud. Client,
wo ist der Client? Da, 11. Bam. Probieren wir mal aus. Oh, ich muss ein Update machen.
Das dauert jetzt kurz. Dauert 2-3 Minuten. Update. 176, stimmt. Ja, 3G. So, bei der Gelegenheit
testen wir gleich mal, ob jetzt alle Bilder-Formate funktionieren. Okay. Foggers. Foggers als save
image. Downloads. So. Das bedienen wir jetzt um. CD, Download, Cover nach Foggers. So,
schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt die App jetzt erkennt. Wir wandeln das jetzt in alles Mögliche
um. PG, PNG, und gucken einfach mal, ob der Kram jetzt tut. Also, wo haben wir hier? Files.
Auf. Ich geb alles. So, Fotos 2. Upload. Wie ging das nochmal, dass man die Sachen hoch
lädt? Upload, Downloads, jetzt Foggers. Beides laden wir hoch. Und AIR-JAR-PNG. Aber wir haben
doch schon alles da. Wir haben doch alle Formate da, die wir brauchen. Starts, Slides, Slideshow.
Alles klar. Mal gucken, was die Foto-App davon kann. Okay. Poggers geht. AIR-JAR geht. Aber
mein GIF geht nicht. Mein GIF ist kaputt. Das mag er nicht. GIF mag er nicht. Geht H-E-I-C.
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich weiß nicht, ob FFmpeg das mittlerweile kann. Probieren wir
mal aus. Poggers. H-E-I-C. Kann das FFmpeg? Oh, ich muss Firefox neu starten. JPEG 2000.
Gibt es wirklich, dass das jemand verwendet? Wie, es gibt wirklich keinen? Ist das nicht
Hive? Doch. Das sind die Videos und das andere sind die. Aber das kann das wahrscheinlich
auch nicht. Warum kann das? Das ist jetzt ohne Scheiß das erste. Mal das FFmpeg, was
nicht schreiben kann. Interessant. Dass das wusste, das hätte ich nicht gedacht. FFmpeg
kann sonst alles. Immer. E-ASHA-CLI. Aber die Standardsachen unterstützen sie. Das ist
doch in Ordnung. So und jetzt kommt der knapp Punkt. Warum habe ich noch mal Update gemacht?
Also Nextout Desktop Client wollte ich installieren. Okay, jetzt kommt der knapp. Mal gucken, was
die Suche macht. Mal gucken, ob die Suche jetzt ordentlich funktioniert. Das Test, ob
die Suche ordentlich geht. Files, Textdokument, cac.txt, oder.md meinetwegen. Blank. Hallo.
Chat. Blub. Perfekt. Und jetzt suchen wir mal nach Blub, ob er das jetzt findet. Die Suche
geht immer noch standardmäßig nicht und ich glaube, man kann die Suche auch nicht
standardmäßig einschalten. Da braucht man dann den Elasticsearch Cluster für und solche
Dinger. Ich glaube, das geht nicht. Search. Hä? Warum findet er da nichts und hier findet
er das. Fulltext Search. Guck mal, das wurde nicht mal geupdatet auf 22. Das wird immer
noch nicht funktionieren. Kann ich hier gar nicht installieren, weil nicht geupdatet wurden.
Na toll. Kann man in dem Markt dann auch Bilder aus dem Foto-Folder einbilden? Ja,
das geht. Das funktioniert. Mal gucken, ob die Hilfen dafür haben. Ja, ihr habt mittlerweile
Hilfen dafür, das ist ganz praktisch, weil ich kann mir nie die Sonntagsmerken. Das funktioniert.
Das müssen wir mal gucken, ob der das Markdown rendern kann. Kann man? Hat das irgendwie
die mögliche Markdown Vorschau oder so zu machen? Wobei, das ist ja ist ja quasi schon
so halb halb gerendert. Okay. Ja, aber das funktioniert. Da muss ich so loben, das haben
sie ganz gut gemacht, dass man hier Bilder rein tracken und droppen kann. So, Desktop
Client installiert. Jawoll. Nee, Azure Client macht noch Updates. Hör auf. Ich habe den
Counter mittlerweile längst gelöscht. Okay. Next Cloud Client. Dass da halt keine standardmäßige
Volltext-Suche drin ist, das finde ich doof. Und dass man, dass man einen eigenen Elastic
Search betreiben muss, finde ich auch doof. Man hätte es ja so machen können, dass man
standardmäßig eben. Meine Tasten sind gerade schon am wackeln. Gut, aber ich meine, wer
spielt auch mit Pfeiltasten? Man hätte es ja machen können, dass es standardmäßig
eben kein Elastic Search braucht. Teams hat doch auch keine Volltext-Suche. Doch, ich
glaube schon. Also für Nachrichten und Gedöns auf jeden Fall. Für Office-Dateien wahrscheinlich
nicht, aber da. Ja, gut. Dann musst du es über OneDrive oder Office oder was auch immer
machen. Ich verwende den Dateienkram da drin nicht. Mein Teams ist jetzt ja auch nicht gedacht
jetzt als großartige Pfeil, Pfeilbearbeitungssoftware. Wobei Next Cloud umgedreht eigentlich hauptsächlich
das sein sollte. Also eine Pfeilsharing Software. Oder was heißt Pfeilsharing? Eine Pfeilsynch
Software. So, jetzt machen wir den Next Cloud Client mal auf. Es wäre halt cool, man hätte
es standardmäßig so machen können. Man macht eine Volltext-Suche halt einfach mit
der billigen CREP-Implementierung. Also einfach durchsuchen. Ja, bei jeder Suche. Das wird
zwar langsam bei vielen Dateien, aber für die meisten User mit total lange ausreichend
schnell genug. Sie wollen, na klar, die wollen immer noch Pfeilsharing Software sein. Die
wollen hauptsächlich eine Pfeilsharing Software sein mit noch mehr. Deswegen haben die sich
umbenannt in Hub. Wohingegen Teams standardmäßig alldeutsch eine, wie heißt das, eine Videokonferenz
Software im Kern ist mit ein bisschen Dateien drum herum. Also das würde ich bei Teams nicht
dran messen, dass man Dateien nicht ordentlich durchsuchen kann. Aber Next Cloud möchte
ja eine Dateilsynch Software sein. Wir hätten einen Grund haben, warum sie es nicht einfach
mit CREP implementiert haben. Nö, wahrscheinlich keinen Bock gehabt. Teams ist doch von Funktionen
her Talk, ja, so im Prinzip. Ja, ich auch. Dass die alles mit abfackeln wollen, finde
ich auch verwirrend. Ich muss halt sagen, es fand ich heute gar nicht so schlecht bisher,
was ich gesehen hab. Also die Basics-Sachen funktionieren zum größten Teil mehr halt
auch nicht. Aber leider waren halt so die letzten Versionen über 90% der Funktionen für mich
irrelevant. Von Social-Media-Geschichten zu Talk zu Collaboration-Sachen und so. Ich verstehe,
warum sie das machen. Sie wollen Geld verdienen mit der Geschichte und das müssen sie irgendwelche
Unternehmen verkaufen und dementsprechend bauen die das so, dass es für die eben gut
ist und funktioniert. Aber das ist halt für mich dann als Privatanwender auch nur zweitrangig,
ja. Wenn die Dinger, die ich benutze, nicht ordentlich funktionieren oder eben Probleme
machen, dann muss ich halt nach was anderem gucken. Kann man die nicht als Vorwurf machen,
ja ich würd's wahrscheinlich auch so machen. Hä doch, du kannst den Teams nach Teams suchen.
Achso, nee, du musst in den Teams erst drinnen sein, dass du die Teams suchen kannst, ja.
Stell dir ne Instanz mit 1000 Usern vor und mehr als 100.000 Files. Also, Grab über mehr
als 100.000 Files ist erstaunlich schnell, aber das ist ja überhaupt nicht das, was ich
gesagt hab. Ich hab gesagt, man könnte ne Standard-Implementierung machen, die halt
einfach Crap verwendet, was Probleme macht, wenn's viele Usern werden, aber dann kann
ich ja immer noch ne Elastic Search installieren, wenn ich das dann machen will. Aber für die
meisten User wäre es vollkommen ausreichend, wenn das Ding im Hintergrund Dateien durchcrappt.
Da kommt im Heimbereich niemals irgendjemand an seine Grenzen. Und wenn doch muss er sich
halt, also wenn da doch einer an die Grenzen kommt und ich 2-3 Sekunden warten kann, dann
muss er sich halt ne Elastic Search installieren. Okay, das versteh ich dann. Aber so ne funktionierende
Standard-Implementierung für die Volltext-Suche find ich schon sinnig.
Na ja, was können wir jetzt ausbauen? Good Talk werd ich nie verwenden. Mit wem soll
ich reden? Mit mir selbst? Da brauch ich keine App für. Was ist denn der App-Store?
Was gibt's denn im App-Store sonst noch Schönes? Zeig mal her.
Colabora Online. Das ist diese LibreOffice-Geschichte, ne? Na ja. Ach, das ist schon schade, mir
gefällt's. Hä? Ja gut, das ist doch genau das, was ich grade gesagt hab. Das kann man
so machen. Wo ist denn jetzt dieser? Ja, das ist auch genau das, was ich grade gesagt
hab. Das kann man so machen, da kann man denen doch nicht mal großartig böse drüber
sein. Aber das ist dann für mich im Heimbereich halt dann auch irgendwann nicht mehr interessant.
Wenn's nur noch Funktionen gibt, die ich nicht brauch und die, die ich brauch, nicht ordentlich
implementiert sind, da muss man halt an was anderem gucken. Das läuft dann halt letztendlich
drauf raus. Und ich weiß nicht, ob's auf lange Sicht so
ne sinnvolle Entscheidung ist, auch für Nextcloud, wenn man komplett auf die Heim-User-Bedürfnisse
so scheißt. Wo, wo kommt man jetzt dieses Kollaborer Zeug öffnen?
Gripgrab sucht bei 440 Dateien in 8, äh, Dateien 8 Sekunden. Äh, das, ja klar, das, ich sag
doch, Textdateien durchsuchen auf SSDs ist fucking schnell. Das ist wirklich zackig.
Ich mein, wenn du jetzt natürlich 800.000 Dateien hast und alles ist quasi nur Herr der
Ringe oder irgendwas mit, was weiß ich, wie viel, tausend Millionen Dings, Wörtern, ja
dann, dann mag das anders sein. Aber die meisten Textdateien sind ja nicht so lang.
So, was muss ich machen? Ah, hier, New, New Document. 0W, also. Ich hab, wie oft soll
ich den Kram noch so nennen. Jetzt kommt hier. It's not set up yet. Click here. Use built-in
server. Ja, ne. Built-in server. Darf ich nicht? Ah, Installed from App Store, ok. Und untested,
alles klar. Confirm. Hier, wir machen jetzt, wir installieren uns aber hier. Wollen wir
reloaden? Wir hoffen, dass es jetzt da ist. Hopp. Aha. Ok. Und jetzt? Und jetzt? Äh.
Ok. Mal installiert ist es. Ok. Keine Ahnung. Hopp. Könnte das an meiner Docker Port Weiterleitungsgedöns
jetzt liegen? Ne, Port 8080 ist, ist richtig. Ok, dann nicht. Dann nicht. Ok, dann nicht.
Geht nur mit Domain und passt einem Zertifikat. Ok, da wäre natürlich ne Fehlermeldung mal
ganz praktisch, ne. Hat das Ding eigentlich welche Logs, wo man sowas sieht? Code, wenn
wir es code? Ne. Was ist Nextcloud? Eine, ein Web-Interface für, ähm, Pfeil, also einmal
ne File Sync Software und ne Web-Interface für zig Millionen verschiedene Dinger über
Plugins. Kann man jetzt schlecht, schlecht beschreiben. Nextcloud ist keine Cloud-Lösung
in dem Sinn. Ja, auch wenn das Cloud eben Namen hat. Das ist glaub ich, man kann sich
über die Benamung streiten. Ich mein, nur weil was Cloud im Namen hat, ist es nicht
automatisch Cloud. Es ist ne PHP, es ist ne PHP-Web-Interface mit, äh, verschiedenen Plugins,
was wo man versuchen kann, bestimmte Cloud-Dienste quasi nachzubauen, wenn man die selbst betreiben
will. Haben wir hier irgendwelche Logs? Für dich ist Cloud Dropbox, für mich ist Cloud
alles das, was nicht bei mir lokal auf dem Rechner läuft. Ähm, System? Haben wir irgendwo
Logs oder so vielleicht? Nope. Nope. Yep, Logs. Logging, ah da ist es doch, lul. Ähm,
ok, warum mag der nicht? Der mag nicht, weil sagt der mir nicht. Ok, ja aber es hat ja
schon einer im Chat geschrieben, das ist nur mit Domain und gültigem Zertifikat. Gut,
das krieg ich jetzt für lokal Host, krieg ich leider noch kein gültiges Zertifikat.
Kennen Sie eine bessere Lösung für Bilder-Collaboration? Wie gesagt, ich nicht. Irgendjemand hat vorhin
was vorgeschlagen, wie hieß das denn? Pix? Ne, ähm, Nextcloud Photo Alternative. Hab
ich letztens, entweder heute oder vor ein paar Tagen, aber ich glaube heute hat vorhin
einer was im Chat gepostet. Ich habe vergessen, wie das hieß. Photoprism war das glaube ich.
Ich glaube Photoprism hat vorhin im Chat einer vorgeschlagen. Ist das, kann man das selbst
hosten? Open Source Photomanage powered by Go und TensorFlow, das heißt das ist Fotosoftware
mit AI. Oh Big Brain, Big Brain Photosoftware ist das. Scheint recht beliebt zu sein mit
15.000 Sternen. Das können wir auch mal aus. Gucken wir uns mal die Demo an. Also da muss
ich sagen, Chico ist schöner. Aber der, aber der ist besser fotografiert. Aber Chico ist,
Chico ist... Pog. Ich finde übrigens das Bild, wo ist das Bild von Chico hier im,
hab ich überhaupt in meinem Board ein Bild von Chico? Ne, ich doch nicht. Katz FPS,
true, lulwe. So, Suche. Gucken wir mal. Cat. Oh, das ging schnell. Jawoll, dicke Katz
am Start, Poggers. Ja, das macht auch einen ganz guten Eindruck. Also auch von der Geschwindigkeit,
das macht echt einen guten Eindruck. Moment, warum bewegt sich das? Das ist doch ein Bild.
KegWaite. Leute, ich bin verwirrt. Ach, das ist diese Apple, diese, ja ja, die kenne
ich. Das ist, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie diese Funktion heißt, aber das ist mir auch schon
am iPhone aufgefallen. Genau, iPhone Zeugs. Ne, ne, das ist keine AI-Power eingerechnete
Bewegung. Ist aber doof, dass man sich das dann nicht in groß angucken kann, oder? Ach
so, doch. Geht doch. Das ist doch mal tatsächlich ganz ordentlich gemacht. Also, bis das ne,
Leute, bis das ne AI so berechnen könnte, da vergeht noch ein bisschen was. Also, da
habe ich jetzt, jetzt heute im Stream und ich hab's auch irgendwo anders schon gelesen,
jetzt paar, paar gute Sachen von gehört. Ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert. Ich hab's
noch nicht ausprobiert, aber das soll wirklich ganz nice sein. Ich überleg grad, was können
wir noch großartig ausprobieren? Next Cloud Kontakte App, die ist wahrscheinlich noch
so wie immer. Also außer, dass es jetzt Circles gibt. Gibt's das als App für Next Cloud?
Ja, das wär's jetzt. Da hätte man eine ordentliche Fotofunktion. So, Talk bringt mir auch nichts.
Ich wollte, ich wollte mal in App Store gucken, was mir das vorschlägt. So, gibt's noch was
wie All Apps vielleicht? Was haben wir denn hier alles zu bieten? Bla, bla, bla. Brauchen
ich Circles? Comments. Dashboard, Deck, Delete Files, Mail, alles, Fotos, Text. Ja, irgendeine
Streaming haben wir. Ach, das ist auch schon alles, Moment, das ist schon alles. Ich muss,
Verschlüsselungskram, Maps. Jetzt haben wir Maps jetzt aktiviert, wo ist Maps? Yep, Maps.
Wo ist es denn? Da, Maps. Ok, guck mal, Frankfurt. Hesse, genau. Ah, das ist Open Street Maps.
Ja, das ist, ja ist auch. Das erkennt man gleich, das ist die Standard Open Street Maps
Geschichte. Ja gut, das ist ne App. Your Devices. Cool, gibt's nicht. Your Photos, your Contacts,
your Tracks. Oh, gut, das ist halt ne äußerst rudimentäre Map Anwendung. Also sowas, also
rein vom Webinterface machst du sowas in Viertelstunde. Location League, schon wieder, oh nein. Das
mache ich über meinen Home Assistant. Ja, sagte ich mir schon, steht ja oben da. Das
mache ich über meinen Home Assistant. So, soll ich lieber Flask oder Node.js lernen?
Das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen. Welche Programmiersprache willst du denn benutzen?
Das ist ja die deutlich, das ist ja die deutlich interessantere Frage. Und ist es deine erste
Programmiersprache? Oder ist das, kannst du schon was anderes? Wobei man halt sagen muss,
Flask und Node.js ist jetzt eigentlich, wie sagt man so, ein Apfelbirnenvergleich. Flask
ist ein Minimal Web, ne wie nennt man das so, Minimal Python, Minimal Backend Framework
und Node.js ist die Chrome 4.8 Runtime für Server. Also du müsstest eher fragen, soll
ich Flask oder Express lernen oder sowas zum Beispiel. Du hast Java? Ja gut, wenn du Java
kannst, dann würde ich dir tatsächlich sagen, versuch dich mal ruhig ein bisschen an Javascript,
weil an Frontend Geschichten, was in Javascript ist, kommt man eh nicht vorbei. Aber dann
würde ich nicht Node.js lernen, sondern dann würde ich versuchen ein bisschen Frontends
zu lernen, also im Browser. Ich würde mir dann angucken, was sind aktuelle Javascript
Frameworks. Da würde ich vielleicht mal so, also ich persönlich würde mit sowas wie
Vue.js anfangen, nachdem ich die Javascript Basics drinne hab. Also ich würde wahrscheinlich
Frontend jetzt mir angucken, also wenn du schon Javas, Java ist eine Supersprache fürs
Backend und man kommt an Frontend Geschichten, Javascript, HTML, CSS nicht vorbei. Das ist
eigentlich eine sinnvolle Ergänzung, die man als Entwickler immer braucht, immer. Javascript
im Frontend. Und klar, du kannst auch Node.js lernen, beziehungsweise Javascript mit Node.js,
aber ich fände es sinnvoller, wenn du schon eine Backendsprache kannst, jetzt ein bisschen
Frontend sich anzugucken. Was ist Fadin, Alter? Fadin? Ach Java, ok. Ja da bist du bei mir
genau richtig, du weißt ja, wenn ich das Backend machen würde, würde ich das auch machen
in C-Sharp. Oder beziehungsweise die Sachen, die ich bisher gemacht habe, webtechnisch
waren eigentlich alle mit C-Sharp Backend. Was macht eigentlich der Preischamp? Funktioniert
er noch? Ja, funktioniert noch, exellent. Aber Grafikkartenpreise gehen runter. Jetzt
muss ich nur noch 2400 Euro bezahlen für eine Grafikkarte im Durchschnitt versus 1500
Euro UVP. Das stimmt zum Teil sogar, in C-Sharp hast du sehr viele Features mittlerweile drin,
die musst du aber nicht verwenden, wenn du keinen Bock drauf hast und die machen es nicht
langsamer. Also wenn du kein Pattern-Matching ausschweifen verwenden willst, musst du nicht,
das geht trotzdem und macht es nicht langsamer. Nicht so wie bei C++, nicht so wie bei C++,
wo man die Sprache durch neue Sachen so krass kompliziert macht, dass keiner mehr durchblickt.
Ja, aber Aliexpress hat leider dafür keine API. Wobei, die Chinesen China Miner verkaufen
ihre Grafikkarten ja nicht über Aliexpress, die verkaufen ihre Grafikkarten ja über dieses
chinesische Ebay. Ich weiß aus dem Kopf gerade nicht, wie das heißt. Es gibt so ein China
Ebay, darüber verkaufen gerade die ganzen China Miner ihre Grafikkarten. Das weiß ich
nicht. Leute, Chat, für die die Ahnung haben, kann Java mittlerweile Assink Await? Ich würde
mal drauf tippen, ja, aber wissen tue ich nicht. Nein? Okay, das sagt. Ich hätte jetzt
eigentlich gedacht, das können sie mittlerweile. Aber Kotlin kanns. Was dann wiederum heißt,
dass das JVM technisch eigentlich kein Problem ist, sowas umzusetzen. Ach, auch nicht. Ich
weiß schon, warum ich meine Sachen in C-Sharp mache. Na ja, man kann nicht alles haben,
außer man programmiert in C-Sharp. Okay. Die nehmen mittlerweile schon PS4s zur Mining,
warum sollte man denn sowas machen? Der PS4 ist ja nicht mal sonderlich schnell. Oh, Marc,
Marc, Marc, Marcel, Marcel. Kannst du noch wechseln? Such dir lieber was anderes, Alter.
Das ist schon in Ordnung. Also es ist kein Grund, weshalb ich meine Ausbildungsstelle
wechseln würde, aber trotzdem. Also Visual Basic ist so wirklich. Also ich meine, ich
nehme mal an, es ist visualbasic.net, aber selbst Microsoft sagt, die haben keinen Bock,
den Kram zu updaten. Übrigens, ich habe Subscriber vergessen hier. Ice Freak von einer Stunde
schon. Lull, Alter, nicht gesehen. Danke für den Sub, richtig feifett. Hyper-Subscriber.
Thomas Cool vor einer Stunde, elf Monate. Danke schön für den Sub hier. LiamAffa auch
am Start. Sandro. Ich habe euch alle übersehen heute. Java und Cobol, optimale Kombination.
Leute, wir haben auf der Arbeit uns einen Cobol-zu-Java-Compiler, einen Enterprise-Cobol-zu-Java-Compiler
gekauft. Das heißt, unsere ganze Cobol-Software läuft jetzt eigentlich in Java, aber ist
immer noch Cobol. Das Schlechteste aus zwei Welten, Alter. Ja, dem bleibt nichts anderes
übrig. Auf der anderen Seite unterschätzt nicht, wie lange man Legacy-Zeug weiter verwenden
kann, ohne was dran zu ändern. Das wird wahrscheinlich nie umgestellt. Es bleibt immer auf.NET 3.1,
.NET Core 3.1, was ja der Vorgänger von.NET 5 ist, weil Microsoft Benahme und Kacke sind.
Mit was? Mit welcher? Weiß man das schon? Mit was? Mit Office 730, oder?
Ja, das geht, aber das ist hässlich as fuck. Generell, so diese ganzen Cross, wie heißt
denn das, diese transpiling Geschichten, gibt es ja für viele andere Sprachen auch,
aber das ist meistens eklig. Ich habe beispielsweise gesehen, dass die mal ein Projekt hatte, hatte
mal Java, hatte mal Java zu C-Sharp gemacht und das war halt, es lief, ja, aber schön
war das nicht. Haben wir auch, verstorben sind die bei uns nicht, aber wir haben gerade
im Backend-Finanz, also in diesem Finanz-Backend-Sektor, wo noch ganz viel IBM-Mainframe-Geschichten
am Start sind, haben wir sicherlich auch noch Cobalt-Programme und sonstige Dinge, die sind
so alt, dass der Entwickler nicht mehr lebt. Wird Jamals, wird Java jemals wirklich kompiliert?
Wird es nicht einfach zu Java-Bytecode? Es muss irgendwann mal umgewandelt werden zu
Code, den deine CPU ausführen kann, anders geht das gar nicht. Das heißt, alles wird
früher oder später mal umgewandelt in ausführbaren Code. Anders da funktioniert es ja nicht
wirklich. Ich meine, es wird vielleicht nie, okay, es wird vielleicht nie ahead of time
alles auf einmal kompiliert, aber die Übergänge sind ja heute eh fließend, also du hast ganz
wenig noch reininterpretiertes, du hast auch mal zu Zwischendinger. Ich meine, der Vorteil
von interpretierten Sachen ist ja ganz klar, es startet schnell, also im Vergleich zu kompilieren
und sonst wie, ich drücke ausführen und es fängt an. Dafür ist die Ausführgeschwindigkeit
oftmals nicht so zackig. Deswegen macht man es heute in der Regel so, also es ist zumindest
so ein Ansatz, was die meisten Sprachen, wo das früher interpretiert wurde, heute machen,
Javascript macht das so und Python macht das auch so, Ruby macht das so, die machen so
einen Zwischenschritt, die machen so eine Art, so ein bisschen so wie das Java und C-Sharp
auch machen, die machen so eine Art Bytecode-Geschichte draus und während es läuft versuchen sie
dann das noch zu optimieren. Also bei Javascript ist es so, Javascript läuft erstmal ganz
normal interpretiert los und V8, also diese Javascript Engine von Google, die versuchen
da, sie machen da ganz abgedrehte Dinge, die versuchen dann den, also zu erkennen, was
der ressourcenintensive Execution-Fahrt ist in diesem Code und den versuchen sie schon
zu optimieren und spätestens nachdem du einmal durchgelaufen bist, haben sie dann optimierten
Code daraus generiert, dass der nächste Durchlauf schneller ist. Deswegen hat man es übrigens
manchmal so, dass Webseiten, die viel Javascript verwenden, dass die beim ersten Mal laden,
kurz ruckeln und danach wunderbar laufen. Also V8, also das was Google mit V8 gemacht
hat ist massiv Big Brain, also da platzt der Kopf eigentlich schon fast. Ihr müsst euch
mal überlegen, die haben es geschafft mit V8, dass Javascript fast so schnell ist wie
C++ fast. Es gibt Sonderfälle, da verkackt die Performance komplett. Also es gibt beispielsweise,
wenn du Schleifen, also wo zumindest, ich habe einen Talk gesehen von einem V8 Entwickler
und er hat gezeigt, wo sie noch Schwierigkeiten haben, Optimierung einzubauen in Javascript.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du eine Schleife hast, wo dynamisch in der Schleife quasi davon abhängig
ist, wie oft die Schleife läuft und solche Dinge. Du rechnest quasi in der Schleife irgendwie
neu aus, wie lange die Schleife läuft oder wo sie auch Probleme haben ist, wenn du Arrays
hast, wo nicht genau klar ist, wie viele Elemente. Also es gibt so ein paar Cases, wo es schwierig
ist, Javascript zu optimieren, aber in den meisten Fällen ist Javascript in Chrome
saumäßig schnell, zumindest im Vergleich zu früher. Firefox nutzt nicht V8, Firefox
haben so eine eigene Javascript-Geschichte, die im Prinzip das Gleiche macht, nur nicht
ganz so gut. Oder sie betteln sich ein bisschen, wer besser ist, aber im Durchschnitt würde
ich sagen, hat V8 schon die Nase vorne. Also das ist wirklich richtig Next-Level-Shit,
was die machen. Ihr müsst euch mal angucken. Benchmarks V8 vs C++ oder C, ihr müsst euch
das mal angucken. Moment, wie hieß denn diese Benchmark-Seite nochmal? Da gab es noch so
eine Benchmark-Seite, wo du... Nein, nein, nein. Languages. Wie ist das denn? Wo die
Leute versuchen, die optimiertesten Programme für ihre jeweilige Programmiersprache einzustellen.
Und da muss man mal wirklich Javascript und C und C++ vergleichen, man sieht dann ist...
Also Performance-Potenzial ist da kein großer Unterschied mehr. Okay, ich weiß, da ist
viel Rust drinne. Ich weiß, da ist viel Rust drinne. Tech-Empower, das kann tatsächlich
sein, dass ich das meine. Ja, nee. Das ist der Webseiten-Benchmark. Nee, den meine ich
nicht. Aber sowas, den kenne ich auch. Ich meine sowas ähnliches, aber für... Das da
könnte es sein. Nee. Ach fuck. Javascript. Weil das könnte, das könnte es tatsächlich
sein, dass ich die Seite meine, dass die einfach nur im Dark-Reader-Kacke aussieht. Ich bin
geplantet, Leute. So, wie können wir das jetzt vergleichen? Javascript-Notes. Wo ist denn
Javascript jetzt? Calc-Wade. Ich bin zu dumm, die Seite zu finden, ich meine. Scheiß drauf.
Ja, zumindest sieht man dann, wenn man die Seite gefunden hätte, dass Performance-mäßig
tatsächlich in ähnlichen Regionen spielt mittlerweile. Dankeschön für den Sub. Und
zwar, wer hat denn hier... Torradchen, dankeschön. 1, 8, 7, 5 Monate BigBrain-Sub, ja. Passiv
6-Head-Time. Javascript auf dem letzten Platz. Echt, wo? Ich finde, ich finde die Seite echt
nicht. Ich check das nicht. Node, was? Node.js versus, ach, ich muss nach Node suchen, ok.
Node.js versus C++. Ja, guckt mal. Das ist kein so großer Unterschied. Hier, hast du
die Sachen in C++. Läuft, das läuft 666 Millisekunden. Und das hier läuft, das ist
doppelt so schnell, also doppelt so schnell bzw. doppelt so langsam hier. Das ist kaum
noch ein Unterschied. Ja gut, Memory ist klar. Ja. Da muss die ganze Node.js-Runtime laufen.
Memory ist ja klar. Aber Memory, in dem Fall, in diesem Maß stehen... Oh. Ich wollte nicht
den Franzosen einplenden, sondern einen Stehender. Gut, manche Sachen ist halt nicht gut. Wo du
viele Objekte und Sachen im RAM anlegst, ist halt vorbei. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, seht
ihr das? Die Performance technisch ist Javascript in Node nicht bedeutend langsamer als C++.
Node ist aber Single-Threaded. Ich glaube nicht. Ich habe aber keine... also die Basic-Event-Loop-Geschichten
mit IO und so werden wahrscheinlich Single-Threaded sein, aber du kannst garantiert Multithreading
machen in Node irgendwie. Habe ich noch nie gemacht. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Geht bestimmt. Ist wahrscheinlich scheiße zu programmieren, ja. Node.js Multithreading,
keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Es muss funktionieren, aber halt wahrscheinlich nicht
so schön integriert. Also Art Web-Worker-Geschichte jetzt in Node, oder? CPU-Auslastung? Ja, genau.
Work Single-Threaded. Was man hier aber auch schön sieht, ist, dass sich nicht alle Aufgaben
wirklich super parallelisieren lassen. Ich meine, nur weil die CPUs 100% ausgelastet sind,
heißt das ja noch nicht, dass man jetzt auch wirklich die Arbeit optimal verteilt hat.
Es könnte ja sein, dass man dadurch, dass man vier CPUs hat, extra Arbeit machen, also
extra... keine Ahnung, dass man nochmal sortieren muss danach oder so, dass man das ordentlich
wieder als Ergebnis zusammenbekommt oder sowas. Also Multithreaded heißt nicht automatisch
doppelt so schnell mit doppelt so vielen Kern. Aber hier läuft es, hier läuft das Multithreaded.
Node. Ah. Zumindest, was ich sagen wollte, ist, dass das Performanstechnisch, also erstaunlich
schnell ist mittlerweile JavaScript. Sowohl im Browser als auch mit Node.js, weil Node.js
und Browser kommt ja aufs gleiche raus, ist beides V8. Zumindest im Chrome. Und man kann
garantiert Multithreaded machen in Node. Aber es ist wahrscheinlich nicht in der Sprache
jetzt auch im Frame oder zumindest in der Standard Library wahrscheinlich keine großartigen
Hilfen eingebaut. Man kann übrigens mittlerweile sogar Multithreading machen im Browser mit
Web-Workern. Das funktioniert, aber das macht kaum einer. Und das ist aber auch nur interessant
für Hintergrund, also wirklich für Sachen, die nix mit dem GUI zu tun haben. Also wenn
du im Hintergrund, keine Ahnung, wenn du ein Spiel programmierst oder so, vielleicht im
Hintergrund irgendwas machen musst, dann mag das sinnvoll sein. Wenn du irgendwie Minecraft
im Browser programmierst und musst Weltgenerierung machen im Hintergrund oder so, keine Ahnung,
dann ist das sinnvoll. Aber nachdem ein Browser in der Regel eigentlich was macht, damit daraus
dann ein UI-Change resultiert. Weil das eben das ist, wofür ein Browser da ist, dass man
was sieht. Ja, wird selten verwendet. Ey, wir sind jetzt ein bisschen vom Thema abgekommen.
Gibt es jetzt noch irgendwas, was wir in Nextcloud ausprobieren können? Fach AI, Blockchain,
Needs-Game, klar, mit Blockchain und AI ist alles besser. Wissen wir ja. Wann kommt der
Wubblos Community-Minecraft-Server? Ich hatte mal einen Minecraft-Server, Leute. Das ist
da, wo der Kaboom immer nackig rumgelaufen ist. Ja, da muss man sich sogar bewerben für.
Ist das hier, wo der Kaboom nackig rumrennt? Äh. Ich hatte mal einen Minecraft-Server.
Ich habe aber nie großartig Minecraft gespielt. Aber ich fand das mega nice. Mein Haus.
Na gut. Ja, ich hatte mal einen Minecraft-Server. Aber ich habe nie großartig Minecraft gespielt.
Wie viele Nicknames hast du eigentlich? Unterschiedliche. Du hast in irgendeinem Video mit dem Friseur
ein paar Mal die N-Bombe getroppt. Nee, garantiert nicht. Ach, ich glaube, ich weiß, was du meinst.
Ja, ich glaube, ich weiß, was du meinst. Das ist da, wo wir um Zucker-Sahne-Süßwaren
unterhalten haben, ne? Ja, das kann sein. Wo wir uns über Schaumküsse unterhalten haben,
das kann sein. Hey, das war 2011. Da hat man da noch nicht dran gedacht, dass das Monka
Tosma wird, ja? Ah ja, ja. Hintergrund hier. Papa-Platte bald obdachlos. Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Er kann verdienen, was weiß ich wie viel mit YouTube und Kram. Da ist bestimmt bald obdachlos.
Was kann die neue Switch? Ein Display haben wir nicht. Neues Display. Leute, ich habe
da gerade durchgescrollt. Ich habe für einen kurzen Moment gedacht, dass der M-Com. Nein,
nicht der M-Com, Alter. Der M-Core. Das ist nicht der M-Core. Das ist auch nicht der M-Com.
Schon das Video zum Freezing-PC gesehen. Ja, das haben wir uns angeguckt. Und ich dachte
mir so, ja, okay. Und weiter. Ja, ich habe das geguckt. Das war eine coole Idee, aber
ja, das war es dann aber auch. Ah Leute, ich habe Kopfweh. Ich gehe jetzt auf. Ich habe
den ganzen Tag schon seit ich angekommen bin mit der Kopfweh. Ah, sorry, falls ich heute
ein bisschen noch verplanter war als sonst. Ich bin gerade nicht so big brain time-ig
unterwegs. 5G Nachwirkung, ja. Aber wie gesagt, der Handyempfang ist gleich viel besser. So,
nachdem sich der Chat das letzte Mal beschwert hat, es gibt keine Outro-Musik, mache ich
euch jetzt Outro-Musik an. Hallo. Genau. Outro-Musik. Erstmal gucken, ist da Frasier und dann kann
ich irgendjemand hosten. Sonsten. Oh ne, was ist das? Lul. Ajaja Games, Alter. Was spielt
er dann wieder für Zeug? Was spielt er dann wieder für Zeug? Das ist irgendein Mobile-Crap,
Alter. Mobile-Crap. Ich weiß, der will von mir nicht gehostet werden, wenn er sowas spielt.
Das hat er mal gesagt. Also, den nervt das dann, wenn ich ihn hoste bei solchen Sachen.
Also Leute, das ist nicht die Originale. Wir müssen einen richtigen Soundtrack suchen.
Jawoll. Guter SNES-Sound. Also, Bettgeleute. Bis morgen früh, macht's gut. See you.